. SO
THAT WE DON'T GET TOO FAR
BEHIND WE'RE GOING TO START THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY. COVER YOUR EARS.
SO WILL BEGIN WITH A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING CHORES. OUR. AB
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN. AB ONE FOUR
TWO TWO GIPSON HAS BEEN POLL BY
THE AUTHOR. OKAY BUT NOW. AND I
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO CLARIFY ON A
PROCEDURAL MATTER TODAY ARM.
BOND A. B. ONE FOUR FIVE ZERO
LACKEY OF THIS BILL IS ON
TODAY' RECONSIDERATION ARM FOR
RECONSIDERATION AND WE
GENERALLY DO NOT TAKE TESTIMONY
ON THESE MATTERS HOWEVER. ON AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY WAS
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED AND IN
THE INTEREST OF FAIRNESS AND
TRANSPARENCY TO BOTH THE
SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS I'VE
DECIDED TO MAKE AN EXCEPTION
AND ALLOW TESTIMONY ON
CONSIDERATION FOR THE THIS BILL
ONLY. IN WEEK. TWENTY ONE MORE
FOR QUORUM AND SO WE WILL IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME AND
CONSIDERATION OF MEMBERS WHO
CAME HERE ON TIME. ARE WE NOW
HAVE A QUORUM. MA'AM SECTOR
CALL THE ROLL JONES SAWYER HERE
LACKEY THEIR POWER CAN. DEEP.
KAMLAGER QUIRK YOUR SANTIAGO
WICKS. QUORUM IS PRESENT- WILL
NOW LOOK AT THE PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE ONE
ITEM AB ONE FIVE NINE NINE
CUNNINGHAM PEACE OFFICERS
RELEASE OF RECORDS I JUST LIKE
TO MAKE ONCE. WHEN STATEMENT-
FIVE INFORM THE AUTHOR THAT- HE
NEEDS TO WORK WITH THE ALL
PARTIES CONCERNED ESPECIALLY
UPON IS TO WORK THROUGH THROUGH
AS IT OF WHICH I HOPE IT GETS
THROUGH HERE AS IT GOES TO.
APPROPRIATIONS. THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES THAT WERE BROUGHT UP TO
ME JUST RECENTLY THAT I HOPE
THAT HE WORKS IT OUT SO THAT WE
CAN GET IT THROUGH- PROBES- IF
NOT- WE WILL HAVE SOME SERIOUS
CONCERNS. SO IS OUR MOTION SO
MOVED. CALL ROLE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AB FIFTEEN NINETY NINE
JONES SAWYER CHEN SIR I LACKEY
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAND DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I
QUIRK. QUIRK I SANTIAGO WICKS.
A CONSENT KALAS ADOPTED. UP MR
LOS YOU MAY BEGIN. ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB TWELVE TEN. ON PACKAGE
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SUFFERS ALL
LET ME CONGRATULATE MISTER
CHAIR ON YOUR BIRTHDAY TODAY AS
WE BEGIN AND I KNOW WITH A
BETTER OF EACH YEAR VERY GOOD I
KNOW THAT THIS IS- PART OF YOUR
BIRTHDAY WISH AS YOU WANT TO
SEE THIS- PARTICULAR BILL AS-
WE WILL BE ACCEPTING GRACIOUSLY
THE COMMITTEE AMENDS AS WELL-
BUT IN ALL SINCERITY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A SPECIFICALLY- THIS
WAS PROPOSED LAST YEAR AND YOU
AND I HAD MET A NUMBER OF
OCCASIONS- TO DISCUSS THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE ISSUE.
ADDRESS AND TRYING TO AND A
FIVE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
COLLABORATION SIMILARLY ALSO
MET WITH THE MY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
INCLUDE YOUR- SPECIFICALLY IN
HAD HOURS OF CONVERSATIONS I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT AS WELL
BUT IT JUST GOES TO THE DUE
DILIGENCE THAT YOU CHEN. CARE
ABOUT THAT AND MUCH APPRECIATED.
THIS IS A VERY IN NOW NARROWLY
TAILORED. EL AL WITH RESPECT TO
PACKAGE THAT SAID I THINK WE'VE
ALL- SEEING OR HAVE BEEN
VICTIMS OF PORCH THEFT WITH THE
ADVENT OF NEW DELIVERIES- TO
OUR HOMES ESPECIALLY DURING THE
HOLIDAY SEASONS ABOUT MEMBERS
THIS IS NOT JUST- AN ISSUE THAT
IMPACTS A WEALTHY COMMUNITIES
IN FACT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN A REPORT BY FOR
PACKAGING ON AMAZON PACKAGE
THAT'S- SHOWED SIX. OF THE
TWENTY TOP CITIES IN THE UNITED
STATES WERE IN CALIFORNIA SIX
OF THE TOP TWENTY CITY SAN
FRANCISCO NUMBER ONE OAKLAND
SACRAMENTO SAN JOSE LOS ANGELES
AND LONG BEACH SO WE WERE VERY
MUCH. TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
EVERY DAY TO. THE SPECTRUM- AND
THIS MAKES AN INTENSE- TO
IDENTIFY THIS ISSUE AT HAND I
WITH ME TODAY'S JEFF RUBIN WITH
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AS WELL AS
TIFFANY MATHIS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU YOU MAY
BEGIN. CHAIRPERSON MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE STUDENT HIS ARM I
HAVE A COLD AND SO YOU HAVE
FIVE MINUTESALL TOGETHER WITH
THE WAY YOU YOU PARSE IT OUT.
OKAY WHEN AB TWELVE TEN WAS
ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED IT WAS IN
RESPONSE TO A GROWING PROBLEM.
SOMETHING LIKE OVER ONE THIRD
OF AMERICANS HAVE EXPERIENCED
AT LEAST ONE THEFT FROM THEIR
DOORSTEP. OUR. ACCORDING TO A
RECENT CBS REPORT CALIFORNIA
HAS THE WORST THEFT PORCH THEFT
PROBLEM IN AMERICA 30% OF THE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
PACKAGES THAT ARE BEING TAKEN
OCCUR HERE IN CALIFORNIA. PORCH
PIRACY WHICH WE USES ARE SORT
OF A SHORTHAND FOR COMING ONTO
THE CURTILAGE OF THE HOME AND
STEALING A PACKAGE IS NOT LIKE
DANGERS THAT ARE NOT PRESENT
AND DOES NOT HAVE THE SAME TYPE
OF. IT'S NOT A SITUATION WHERE
SOMEONE MIGHT BE DETERRED FROM
GOING INTO A STORE WHERE
THERE'S OTHER PEOPLE AROUND.
PORCH PIRACY IS A CRIME WHERE.
IT IS EASY THESE PACKAGES ARE
EASY PICKINGS THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY. IT'S EXPLODED. AND
SO BECAUSE IT'S SUCH EASY
PICKINGS BECAUSE WE HAD THIS
EXPLOSION WE NEED SOME SORT OF
DETERRENCE. NO. WHEN THE BILL
WAS INITIALLY INTRODUCED. IT
JUST REQUIRED SOMEONE TO COME
ON TO SOMEONE ELSE'S PROPERTY
WITH THE INTENT TO STEAL. WHAT
THEY EVEN TOOK THE PACKAGE IS
NOT DETERMINED IF ALTHOUGH
OBVIOUSLY IT'S GONNA BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO PROVE UNLESS WE
CAN SHOW A PACKAGE WAS TAKEN.
THE BILL WAS A VERY MEASURED
AND REASONABLE RESPONSE
ESPECIALLY COMPARED TO BILLS IN
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED AND OR PASSED. IT
SIMPLY ALLOWS THE PROSECUTION
IN CERTAIN CERTAIN CERTAIN FOR
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES TO CHARGE
A FELONY DOES NOT HAVE TO BE
CHARGED WITH A FELONY. A JUDGE
CAN MAKE A DETERMINATION HEY
I'M NOT GOING TO ALLOW IT TO GO
FORWARD AS A FELONY. AND SERVE
IT WHATEVER THE MAXIMUM
PUNISHMENT WOULD BE WOULD STILL
BE SERVED IN LOCAL JAIL. SO
WILL THIS BILL DO TURKEY THE
THOUSANDS HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF POTENTIAL INDIVIDUALS WHO
MIGHT BE COMMITTING THIS CRIME.
IT'S NOT GOING TO DETER
EVERYBODY CHANGING AT CHANGING
UP THE PUNISHMENT TO ALLOW FOR
A FELONY PUNISHMENT IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE IS NOT GOING TO
DETER INDIVIDUALS WHO MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE DETERRED BY A
MISDEMEANOR OFFENSE. IT'S ONLY
GOING TO HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
LIMITED DETERRENT EFFECT. BUT
BECAUSE THERE RE MILLIONS OF
THESE CRIMES BEING COMMITTED
EVEN IF JUST ONE OUT OF TEN
PEOPLE ARE DETERRED FROM
COMMITTING THIS CRIME THAT
MEANS THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS.
ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE TO. HAVE
PACKAGES TAKEN FROM THEIR HOME%
THEY'RE NOT GONNA HAVE THE RISK
OF SOMEONE COMING UP TO THEIR
HOUSE AND THEN POTENTIALLY
CAUSING. PHYSICAL INJURY TO THE
PERSON WHO'S TRYING TO TAKE THE
PACKAGE OR BEING PHYSICALLY
INJURED THEMSELVES. SO. WHEN
THIS WAS ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED.
IT ADDRESSED IT IN WHAT WE
BELIEVED WAS THE BEST WAY.
SINCE THE- IN ADDITION TO MADE.
THAT LIMIT THE DETERRENT VALUE.
WE NOW HAVE A LIMITATION IN THE
CURRENT BILL OF NINE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DOLLARS. THAT IS. NOT
GOING TO COVER A LOT OF THE
PACKAGE THAT'S THAT OCCURRED
SOMEONE CAN CAN COMMIT TEN OR
TWENTY PACKAGE STEPS BEFORE
THEY GET TO THAT LIMIT
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE ITEM IS
AND THE VALUE OF THE ITEM IN
THE PACKAGE. FOR THE DETERRENCE
VALUE IS FURTHER LIMITED.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO SHOW A CATCH
SO MANY ACT ONCE YOU HAVE TO
TAKE MORE THAN ONE PACKAGE AND
THE TOTAL HAS TO BE MORE THAN
NINE HUNDRED FIFTY. THE
DETERRENCE VALUE IS DIMINISHED
EVEN FURTHER BECAUSE- IT HAS TO
BE UP TO A HUNDRED NINE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY. IT HAS TO HAVE. MORE
THAN ONE OF THEM. AND IT HAS TO
OCCUR WITHIN TWELVE MONTH
PERIOD. THE DETERRENT VALUE IS
FURTHER DIMINISHED WHEN ALL
THOSE CRITERIA HAVE TO BE MET
AND WE HAVE TO PROVE THAT. IT
WAS DONE IN CONCERT. CAN BE
VERY DIFFICULT TO. OF CAPTURE
ALL THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO. ARE
COMMITTING THE STAFFS AND
COMING UP TO THE PORCH. IF YOU
HAVE THAT YOU'RE ABOUT TO USE
OF EVERYONE'S TIME I'M SORRY
SO. ACTUALLY YOU USED UP
EVERYONE'S TIME SO I'LL GIVE
YOU LIMóN DID COULD YOU WRAP
UP SO I CAN HEAR FROM THE OTHER
WITNESSES TOLD ME JUST. NOW WE
CAN SHOP WITH A- WE CAN CHARGE.
SOMEONE WHO COMMITS A
CONSPIRACY. TO STEAL A PACKAGE
WITH A FELONY READY SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE A NEW
CRIME THAT IN THAT INCREASES
THE DETERRENTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBERS
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUE MISTER RUBIN
AND I JUST WANT TO CAUTION THE
COMMITTEE THAT THESE AMENDMENTS
WATER DOWN THE BILL SO MUCH
THAT IT MAKES IT ALMOST
EFFECTIVELY USELESS I'M A
PROSECUTOR IN STANDPOINT BUT WE
DEAL OR TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND TRY TO
FIND CONSENSUS WHERE WE CAN ALL
AGREE ON. A OPTION TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE IS REASONS WHY THE
A. B. TOLD ME PASSED IN ITS
ORIGINAL FORM. YES GOOD MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STAND FILLS
OUT ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE THE PROBLEM OF PUSH BARS
IS A GROWING PROBLEM IN LOS
ANGELES SPECIAL BECAUSE OF THE
DENSITY IN THE MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING UNITS- WHICH MAKES
PORTS PIRACY ALTHOUGH MUCH
EASIER- WE SHARE THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH PEOPLE US TO MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER. IN OPPOSITION BUT I
MEAN IT'S SUPPORT OR WHATEVER.
IN BETWEEN- AT YOU CAME UP I
WAS COMPOUNDED BIRTHDAY THANK
YOU. RYAN RIVERSIDE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THAT YOU
THANK YOU. MR MEMBERS IVAN
ALTAMURA BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR. MORNING
MR JR MEMBERS COURCELLES OF ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
GRAHAM WARD PRESIDENT OF CBS
AMADOR COUNTY SHERIFF'S
EMPLOYEE BENEFIT ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANY
ANY ANYWHERE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE ANY IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT THANK YOU
. OKAY. GOOD
MORNING AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY
THANK YOU A MARK OF GEORGE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION- I
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
AND THE STAFF FOR THE
AMENDMENTS- HOWEVER SADLY WE'RE
STILL OPPOSED TO THE READY THE
PART THAT MAKES US A FELONY
AND- AS A CITIZEN OF THE NUMBER
TWO CITY IN THE OF LIST OF-
COUNTIES OR MUNICIPALITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN VANDALIZED- I STILL
THINK THAT THIS IS UNNECESSARY.
ID ADVOCATES THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORMS IN THE ATTEMPT
WE'VE HAD TO REVERSE MASS
INCARCERATION ALSO AS MR RUBIN
POINTS OUT THIS IS NOT A
DETERRENT AND IT WOULD MAKE A
FELONY THE SORT OF THE
FOLLOWING CIRCUMSTANCES IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD I IN MANY OF MY
NEIGHBORS ORDER GROCERIES FROM
SAFE WAY AND OTHER- IS TO CART
AND THOSE BILLS FREQUENTLY RUN
TO TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS IN ORDER
ON THERE ARE HOMELESS PEOPLE
THAT LIVE FOUR FIVE BLOCKS FROM
MY HOUSE WITH CHILDREN. IF OF
THOSE PEOPLE COME ON MY PORCH
AND STEAL THE GROCERIES UNDER
THE AMBIT OF THESE THIS LONG
THEY WOULD BE ACTING IN CONCERT
AND COULD QUICKLY COMPILE WHAT
COULD AMOUNT TO A FELONY I
THINK THIS IS NECESSARY CAN BE
PROSECUTED UNDER OTHER LOS
UNDER IT YOU KNOW IF IT'S
APPROPRIATE AND FOR THOSE
REASONS. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NO PHONE. MORNING MR CHAIR
HAVE SAYING GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS HAPPY NEW YEAR- MIKE A
DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WE TO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S ADVERTS
TO NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
AND APPRECIATE THAT STAFF'S
EFFORTS AS WELL UNFORTUNATELY
WE REMAIN OPPOSED- I WOULD ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
AND ALSO. JUST ADD- ALONG THE
SAME LINES AS WHAT SHE WAS
DESCRIBING THAT WERE CONCERNED
THAT A. B. TWELVE TEN COULD BE
USED AS A TOOL TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST HOMELESS PEOPLE PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR IN PARTICULAR WE FEAR
THAT THE BILL COULD BE USED AS
A- STE. ARREST PEOPLE AGAIN.
AND FOR PROPERTY OWNERS ARE
EITHER EXPLICITLY OR IMPLICITLY
BIASED PEOPLE WHO THEY BELIEVE
DO NOT BELONG IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD ON WHILE THESE
ISSUES OF DISCRIMINATION ARE
AND BIAS ALREADY OCCURRED TODAY
WE FEAR THAT THE CREATION OF A
NEW CRIME WILL ONLY EXACERBATE
THAT PROBLEM ON AND LSTLY I
WOULD SAY- YOU KNOW TO THE
EXTENT THAT PACKAGE THAT CRIMES
ARE NOT BEING PROSECUTED TODAY
TO THE EXTENT THAT EXISTING
CRIMES ARE NOT SERVING AS A
DETERRENT. THAT IS A MATTER OF
ENFORCEMENT NOT A MATTER OF
NEEDING A NEW CRIME- AND SO
WITH THAT- I ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU. OR
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
SUSAN GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERS ACOSTA HERNANDEZ
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION PREVENTS
ATTORNEYS PRIVATE PRACTICE AND
PUBLIC DEFENDER OFFICES WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL- IMPRINT
AND ALSO THE EVEN AS AMENDED A
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED. A
CONTAINED IN THE ANALYSIS-
LET'S REMEMBER THAT THIS WOULD
BE IN KANSAS OUR NAMING
ORGANIZATION I WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE PART OF THE PHONE MAIL AS
WAS WHO ARE AT TEN MINUTES MY
POLY DOES DO TENANTS TO DO FIVE
BUT GO AHEAD I THAT IS A TEN.
MY APOLOGIES I'LL MAKE A VERY
BRIEF IT IS INCONSISTENT WITH
THE VOTER. VOTER APPROVED
INITIATIVES I THINK WE HAVE TO
KEEP THAT IN MIND THAT'S WHY
THE LAW IS WHAT IT IS TODAY
BECAUSE OF VOTERS A CALIFORNIA
DECIDED THAT'S WHAT SHOULD BE
WHERE THE THRESHOLD SHOULD BE
THE OTHER THING TO KEEP IN MIND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THESE TYPES
OF THAT. IT IS AN ENFORCEMENT
ISSUE THE OTHER THING IS WE
HAVE A DOLLAR AMOUNT ON THIS
IT'S A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT IN
RETAIL BECAUSE YOU DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT'S IN THE PACKAGE. SO
NOW WE'RE NOW GOING TO
POTENTIALLY CREATE A FELONY FOR
SOMEONE WHO MAYBE DID EVEN AND
TAMMY WAS A SMALL PACKAGE I
THOUGHT WAS GOING TO BE A SMALL
AMOUNT TURNS OUT TO BE
SOMETHING LARGER. A LOT OF
HOMES WITH IT BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY IT'S GONNA REMIND
INS VENT THE VOTER APPROVED
INITIATIVE. IS REASON. TO TAKE
FOR THE TOP. THE BOOK OF. IN
VISIT. YEAH BRING. BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THERE'S- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS I HAVE A COMMENT.
FIRST OF ALL I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR A- ACTUALLY
RECOGNIZING A PROBLEM IT'S A
VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM FOR MANY
PEOPLE AND- I AND- AS WAS
ECHOED BY SOME OF THE COMMENTS
ALREADY WISH THAT IT DID GO
FURTHER I KNOW YOU'RE TEMPTED
FOR THAT. BUT IT IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND- I JUST
A- I'M EXTREMELY FRUSTRATED BY.
THE REALITIES THAT THAT SOME OF
OUR LEGISLATION IS A RELEASE TO
THEFT HAS RESULTED I JUST WANT
TO SHARE VERY BRIEF STORY
BECAUSE IT'S VERY REAL AND IT.
IT TELLS. THE REAL
CIRCUMSTANCES WERE DEALING WITH
AS A SOCIETY. I AM A VERY
CLOSE. PERSON WHO JUST SHARED
WITH ME WHO WORKS IN RETAIL.
AND THEY WORK IN A MALL IN MY
DISTRICT AND- THIS PERSON
HAPPENS TO BE A DOESN'T HAS
SOME PLAY THAT THAT CAME TO ME.
THEN SHE INDICATED TO ME THE
FRUSTRATION SHE HAD BECAUSE-
WHERE SHE WORKS THERE IS. A
COUPLE OF PEOPLE THAT WERE-
GATHERING CLOTHING AND CREATED
TO ARM FULLS OF CLOTHING. AND
PROCEEDED TO WALK OUT THE
ALARMS WENT OFF. AND SHE LOOKED
AT HER MANAGER AND HER MANAGER
SHOOK HER HEAD NO. AND LET HER
GO LET THEM GO SHE SAID THERE
WAS PROBABLY THREE OR FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS OF CLOTHING.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE THAT IS
PERMEATING RIGHT NOW THAT
THERE'S NO ACTION BEING TAKEN.
AND THE PENDULUM HAS SWUNG WAY
TOO FAR THE OTHER WAY. AND I DO
BELIEVE IN BALANCE AND WE'RE IN
A VERY VERY IMBALANCED
CIRCUMSTANCE RIGHT NOW. BUT I.
I HARDLY SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE
IT'S A PORTION OF JUSTICE THAT
OUR SOCIETY IS STARVING FOR.
AND ONE OF THE COMMENTS
MENTIONED INITIATIVES STAND BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THERE IS GONNA BE
AN INITIATIVE TO TRY TO BALANCE
THIS OUT AND- WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY YOU MAY CLOSE IT MR
RESTORE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO
A SUMMER AS BY STATING THAT
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT I THINK
WE ALL KNOW SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN
A VICTIM IN FACT WITH THE
ADVENT OF TECHNOLOGY EVEN WITH
RING AND THE OTHERS YOU HAVE
THE EVIDENCE IN WHICH
PERPETRATORS KNOW THAT THEY CAN
GET AWAY WITH THIS- BUT THIS IS
JUST A SMALL STEP TO SAY THIS
IS THE FIRST POLICY HEARING AND
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR TO
CONTINUE TO TRY TO DRIVE THE
ISSUE FORWARD. AND WAS ALSO
KNOWN THAT- THE VICE TO THIS
VICE CHAIR THIS IS ALSO
SPONSORED BY THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
THERE WERE TWO DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS THAT WENT ON THE ROAD
IN SUPPORT OF PROP FORTY SEVEN-
SO THIS BY NO MEANS IS ANY
ATTEMPT TO LOOK AT- SOME OF THE
ARGUMENTS THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT
A DISPROPORTIONATE HURTING
OTHER COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
RAPPER. HAVING A CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW WE THOUGHT. CRITICS
FOR THE CONVERSATION AND
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AS THIS LEAVES THE FIRST
POLICY. COMMITTEE AND HOPE THAT
WE CAN FIND TO SOME
ACCOMMODATION ACCORDINGLY. AND
AS CHAIR I WANT TO THANK. ON
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH-
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE STAFF OF
AND THE CHAIR OF I'VE MADE A
COMMITMENT. TO WORK WITH YOU TO
TRY TO FIND THAT BALANCE. IT'S
KIND OF IRONIC THAT. BOTH SIDES
HAITI MEMBERS WHICH SOUNDS GOOD
TO ME- AND THAT THEY'RE NOT
FULLY ON BOARD WHICH IS WHY.
HOPEFULLY IT STARTS TO
CONVERSATION BECAUSE TRYING TO
DRIVE THAT BALANCE BETWEEN
ACTUALLY. GOING AFTER PEOPLE
WHO ARE DOING THIS ON A
CONSISTENT BASIS- FOR A GUEST
BOOK PROFIT IS WHAT WERE THEY
THINKING AS OPPOSED TO TRYING
TO FIND. AND I WILL USE ON ONE
HAND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MAYBE
DETERRENTS FOR PEOPLE. WHO ARE
CRIMINALS WHO WANT TO DO THIS
AS OPPOSED TO PEOPLE WHO ARE AT
THE POVERTY LEVEL OR BECAUSE OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES HOW COME WE
BUY THEM A JOB. HOW CAN WE GET
HIM OFF DRUGS HOW CAN WE MAKE
SURE THAT THEY DOESN'T REOCCUR.
I DON'TTHINK THEIR MUTUAL
EXCUSE SCHOOLS OF AND I THINK
THAT'S BEEN. I THINK THAT'S
BEEN OUR CHALLENGE OF HOW CAN
YOU BLEND. THE TWO IN A IN A
SEVENTY TWO WAY AND SO- I LOOK
AT THIS BILL AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING NOW. AS MAYBE THE START.
OF BRIDGING THAT SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO GO TO ABOUT SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO CONSTANTLY GO
BACK AND FORTH WITH ONE
ANOTHER- ESPECIALLY WHEN I HEAR
BOTH SIDES SAY THE SAME THING.
THAT WE DO NEED TO COME UP
WITH. AVENUES TO HELP PEOPLE.
WHO ARE ON DRUGS WHO MAY BE A
MOTHER WHO HAS TO FEED THEIR
KIDS. WILL WE SHOULDN'T
CRIMINALIZED THEM AND EXPECT
THEM. TO BE ABLE TO GET OUT OF
THE POVERTY CYCLE BY PUTTING A
FELONY ON THEM AND THEN SAY OH
YEAH YOU'LL BE ABLE TO COME
BACK IN SOCIETY AND BE ABLE. TO
SURVIVE BUT WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS.
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO RENT AN
APARTMENT THEY MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO GET A JOB IF YOU YOUNG YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO. JOIN THE
MILITARY I MEAN AS A WHOLE ONCE
YOU GET A- FELONY ON YOU. YOUR
LIFE SPIRALS. INTO THE SCHOOL
PRINT WHICH I KNOW THAT'S NOT.
YOUR INTENT. AND THAT'S NOT
WHAT I THINK THE D. A.'S
OFFICE. AS I SAID I DON'T
THINK- PEOPLE ONLY ASIDE. WHILE
ON THE OTHER SIDE. WE DO HAVE
TO PROSECUTE PEOPLE. AND WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THOSE THAT
WANT TO BECOME CRIMINALS I WANT
TO BE CRIMINAL. THAT DESK THEIR
SOLE CONCERN IS TO DO THAT AND
BECOME A PLAGUE ON THE SOCIETY.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DETER
THEM. OR THE HOLD THEM OR KEEP
THEM AWAY FROM SOCIETY SO HOW
DO YOU CREATE. THAT BALANCE AND
THAT'S WHAT I MAKE THAT'S KIND
OF THE PLANE BILL WERE ON AND
SO I'M HOPING THAT WE CAN ALL
GET INTO ROOM. AND UNDERSTAND
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET TO THIS IS WHERE OUR
ASPIRATIONS ARE. AND MAYBE YOUR
BILL MISTER LOW. TO BE TH
OPENING- FOR THAT AND THAT'S
WHY NOW WE ARE SUPPORTING IT-
I'M- I'M OPTIMISTIC THAT WHEN
WE GET TO THAT PLACE- NOT ONLY
BOTH SIDES STILL DON'T LIKE BUT
WE MAY START THE DISCUSSION OF
HOW WE CAN BRIDGE THE GAP.
BETWEEN REALLY AREN'T SMART AND
CRIED AND TOUGH ON CRIME. THANK
I WITH THAT TEACHERS RECOMMEND
AN AYE VOTE. ON A. B. TWELVE
TEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY I
BAUER-KAHAN BACK HE HAD I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER NOT
BOATING QUIRK QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WICKS.
MEASURE THE MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU
. NEXT ITEM IS MET MR
H. OUR- AB NINE OH FOUR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'D LIKE TO START OFF BY
THANKING YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
ALSO MEMBERS OF YOUR STAFF- FOR
THEIR HELP US TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE OPPOSITION SO CONCERNS
TO THAT END I HAVE AGREED TO
AMEND THE BILL IN THE PRIVACY
COMMITTEE TO READ AS FOLLOWS.
THE REFERENCE TO SOFTWARE IS
NOT INTENDED TO EXPAND THE
AUTHORITY OF THE GOVERNMENT
ENTITY TO USE SOFTWARE FOR
SURVEILLANCE PURPOSES UNDER THE
CHAPTER OR ANY OTHER LAW. THIS
BILL AB NINE OH FOUR IS
CURRENTLY IN PRINT SEEKS TO
ENSURE THAT GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
CANNOT USE TRACKING SOFT WORD
THAT PERMITS THE TRACKING OF
MOVEMENT OF A PERSON OR- OBJECT
WITHOUT A WARRANT. CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES WHICH WARNED SO TO BE
USED. MR INSTALLING A TRACKING
DEVICE WAS SERVING A WARRANT ON
A THIRD PARTY POSSESSOR OFF THE
TRACKING DATA. HOWEVER WITH NEW
TECHNOLOGY IT IS NO LONGER
NECESSARY FOR AN OFFICER TO
MAKE ANY PHYSICAL CONTACT WITH
THE DEVICE PERSON OR VEHICLE TO
INSTALL SUCH A DEVICE IN ORDER
TO TRACK AN INDIVIDUAL ON THE
CONTRARY THEY SIMPLY NEED TO
HOW OF WIRELESS ACCESS TO
DOWNLOAD TRACKING SOFT WORD
THAT WILL PROVIDE INVESTIGATORS
WITH. THE INFORMATION THAT
THESE. OUR BECAUSE CURRENT LAW
THIS EXPLICITLY DEFINED DEVICE.
BUT TELL THERE IS AMBIGUITY IN
THE SURROUNDING LANGUAGE THAT
IT MUST BE ATTACHED TO AN
OBJECT OR SOMETHING. OUR SUCH
AS A MECHANICAL DEVICE SO THIS
BILL WOULD CLARIFY THAT A
TRACKING DEVICE INCLUDES ANY
SOFT WORD THAT PERMITS THE
TRACKING OF THE MOVEMENT OF A
PERSON. OR OBJECT FOR PURPOSES
OF THE STATUTE ALSO THE
OPPOSITION HOUSE- RAISED THE
CONCERN THAT WE ARE GRANTING
NEW POWERS TO GOVERNMENT AND
HE'S- QUITE THE CONTRARY THE
AMENDMENTS THAT I REFERENCED
EARLIER WILL ADDRESS THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE. IF IT DOES
NOT ARE. ACTIVELY ENGAGED WITH
THE OPTION TO OUR LOOK AT THE
ISSUE CLOSELY AS WE PROGRESS SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR EITHER. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE
FIVE MINUTES YOU CAN USE IT ALL.
BUT YOUR YOUR FIVE. THIS IS
YOUR NUMBER. BECAUSE OF THE
LATE IN AS WE HAVEN'T. WE DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICIAL SUPPORT
POSITION ON THE LEGISLATION
THAT. THIS WE DON'T HAVE
OFFICIAL- SUPPORT POSITION ON
THE LEGISLATION YET HOWEVER-
TALKING WITH- ARE EXPERTS IN
OUR OFFICE ON GPS TRACKING
SOFTWARE TRACKING SEARCH
WARRANTS OUR OFFICE BELIEVES
THAT NOT ONLY IS THIS
APPROPRIATE BUT THIS IS THE
POLICY IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMES AND
WISHES TO. TRACK THE MOVEMENTS
OF AN INDIVIDUAL WHETHER. IT
WOULD BE DONE VIA SOFTWARE OR A
MORE TRADITIONAL- MECHANICAL
DEVICES PLACED ON A CAR OR
OTHER OBJECT- WE REQUIRE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO GET A SEARCH
WARRANT FOR THAT WE BELIEVE
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
SUPREME COURT. A RECENT
DECISION ON THE SPOT AND FOR
THAT REASON I RECOMMEND SUPPORT
AND OUR OFFICE HOPES TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL VERY SOON. IS THERE
ANY OTHER. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. QUIRK. SHE LET'S SEE
SO CALM I THINK WE JUST GOT
SOMEBODY COMING UP FOR OUR
DECISION IN AN OPPOSITE IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING MR
GOOD MORNING AND MEMBERS AND
HAPPY NEW YEAR AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO YOU BUT A HAPPY
GOING AROUND. I COUNTY SHERIFF
FOR THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA- WE
RESPECTFULLY MISSED OPPOSED
EIGHTY NINE OH FOR- I WANNA
STEP I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TH<c.cyan> AND HIS STAFF FOR THEIR</c>
OPENNESS AND DISCUSSING OUR
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL- WE
CERTAINLY SHARE THE AIM OF
MAKING SURE THAT CALIFORNIANS
ARE PROTECTED AGAINST UNLAWFUL
SEARCH AND SEIZURE AND- FORWARD
TO CONTINUING. FIND THE WAY
THAT AIM. THIS IN CALIFORNIA
LAW IT IS UNCLEAR WHETHER
FORSMAN HAS AUTHORITY UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES TO REMOTELY
ACCESS AND INDIVIDUALS
ELECTRONIC DEVICE IN ORDER TO
MONITOR THE INDIVIDUALS
ACTIVITY THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
OF EIGHTY NINE- FORCED TO
EXPRESSLY AUTHOR SUCH REMOTE
ACCESS FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
CALIFORNIA LAW. ARE THE DANGER
OF SUCH AUTHORIZATION ARE CLEAR.
ON FORCED KIND OF TOOL AND
ACCESS TO INFORMATION THAT ARE
BEYOND LOCATION INFORMATION
INSTALLING SOFTWARE TO MONITOR
A PERSON'S ACTIVITY ON THEIR
PHONE OR EVEN TO USE THE
PHONE'S MICROPHONE AND CAMERA
TO SPY ON THE PERSON- MOREOVER
IF LAW ENFORCEMENT BEGINS TO
DEVELOP AND USE TOOLS TO
EXPLOIT THE IN VULNERABILITIES
AND GAIN REMOTE ACCESS IT IS
SIR THE SAME TOOLS BY OTHER
ACTORS WITH FAR LESS BENEVOLENT
GOALS IN THE PROTECTION OF
PUBLIC SAFETY. AGAIN WITH A
NUMBER FOR ENGAGE WITH THIS
ISSUE AND LOOK FOR MORE TO DATE
HOWEVER WE ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. YES MISTER CHAIR
MEMBER SAMANTHA CORBIN WITH THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
I'D AFFILIATE MY COMMENTS WITH
OTHER CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE ACLU OF THE
ANALYSIS DOES RIGHTFULLY POINT
OUT PARTICULARLY IN SECTION
FOUR- THE- OF OUR CONCERNS WE
HAVE BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE REGARDING
AMENDMENTS. I WHICH DOES APPEAR
HE INTENDS TO TAKE- AND WILL
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATION
SHOULD THE BILL MOVE FORWARD
TODAY. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES MISS
COME LUGGAGE BEAU IS RIGHT
MISTER QUIRK STARTED. WELL
MISTER CHAIR I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT- BILL GO FORWARD SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
SOMEBODY CAN'T DOWNLOAD
SOFTWARE TO MY PHONE AND- THAT
YOUR INTENTION AND I THINK IT'S
A VERY GOOD ONE AND- SHOULD
THEY COME UP WITH BETTER
LANGUAGE THEN YOU ARE HAVE I
KNOW YOU'LL TAKE IT SO I'D LIKE
TO MOVE THE BELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MUST COME AUGUST OF
YEAH THANK YOU AND HAPPY NEW
YEAR- MR CHOW I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE BEEN A VERY STAUNCH
ADVOCATE FOR. PRIVACY ISSUES
AND SO I- HAVE NO DOUBT THAT
THE- CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED
BY THE ACLU- AND THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION WILL BE
ADDRESSED- IN YOUR COMMITTEE.
THE AND I WAS ACTUALLY CONFUSED
BY SOME OF THE CONCERNS BECAUSE
AS I READ THE BILL IT WAS JUST
LOOKING TO SORT OF RE DEAF.
TRACK VICE IS GIVEN ARE SORT OF
EVOLUTION. THE EXISTENCE OF
SOFTWARE AND YET THE CONCERNS
AROUND THE POTENTIALLY
EXPANSIVE NATURE OF IT I SEE
WHERE THERE IS GIVEN PAUSE SO I
ALSO AM HOPING THAT LANGUAGE
SORT OF CAN BE. MORE NARROWLY
DEFINE- SO THAT WE ARE NOT
CREATING AN END RUN AROUND THE
ABILITY- TO TRACK PEOPLE AND
THE EXAMPLE THAT CAME TO MY
MIND WAS WHAT HAPPENED IN LOS
ANGELES WITH LA D. O. T. AND
SCOOTERS AND ESPECIALLY USING
SOFTWARE. TO TRACK THE MOVEMENT
OF USERS AND ONE ENTITY IS
SAYING WELL IT'S ALLOWING US TO
SORT OF MONITOR CONGESTION AND
TRAFFIC AND ANOTHER ENTITY IS
SAYING YES BUT ALSO- INVADING
FOLKS IS RIGHT PRIVACY YOU'RE
HAVING AN ABILITY TO TRACK
WITHOUT NEEDING A SEARCH
WARRANT AND SO WITH FUZZY. IN
THE BILL THAT I THINK WHAT
REYES- THOUGH- OPPOSE SO I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL IN HOPES
THAT WILL BE ADDRESSED IN THE
SCREEN COMMITTEE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS A YOU MAY CLOSE
MISTER JOHN. LAST ARRIVAL THANK
YOU AND I AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU MR CHOW FOR WORKING WITH
OUR COMMITTEE ONCE WE BROUGHT
UP THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION YOU IMMEDIATELY
WORKED ON THIS WITH OUR LAWYERS
AND OUR STAFF AND- BUT I KNOW
WE WORK REAL HARD TO CRAFT
SOMETHING WE THOUGHT. WOULD
MEET THEIR CONCERNS- LIKE
ANYTHING WHEN YOU GET ABOUT
HOURS IN ROME YOU DON'T ALWAYS
GET TO A CONCLUSION SO I'M
HOPING THAT. D. EIGHT OFFICE
ALONG WITH THE ACO. BECAUSE THE
DA'S OFFICE HAS CONCERNS AND
THE ACO HAVE CONCERNS AND IT
SEEMS TO BE ALL ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION. HOW IS IT
ULTIMATELY IMPLEMENTED- AND I
KNOW THE ONLY WAY AND CORRECT
ME IF I'M WRONG THE ONLY WAY
THAT. THIS CAN BE ACTIVATED
THEY HAVE TO GET A SEARCH
WARRANT TO THE DA'S OFFICE SO
IT IS CRITICAL. THAT AT THE
LAWYERS FROM THE OPPOSITION
MEET WITH OF THE SUPPORTERS AND
MAYBE WE LOCK THEM IN A ROW AB
HAVING HELP HASH OUT THE FINAL
WORDING AS WE MOVE FORWARD
SPECIAL WHEN YOU GO TO
JUDICIARY. WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE
ALL THE LAWYERS TALKING THEN I
WOULD I WOULD IF I WERE YOU
WORK IT OUT BEFORE. SELECT
COMMITTEE. COULD NOT GET TOO
MANY LAWYERS TALKING ABOUT
THIS. SO OF. MY RECOMMENDATION
ADAM- THAT WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS AND- ESPECIALLY SINCE
ROLLING. I NOTICED A BIG ISSUE
BUT IT'S JUST ONE ISSUE. GOOD
YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL ON A. B.
NINE A FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER. HI JONES I YOUR
COMMITTEE THAT'S MY CAN BE
REACHED DISHER MAYBE CAN HELP
FROM THE CHAIR PERSON YEAH.
LACKEY HI LACKEY I OUR CAN
BACKING HAD I'D DEEP. DEEP I
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I QUIRK.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I'D WICKS.
THE MEASURE PASSES GREGORY
MUCHA MEMBERS
. THE ITEM WAS
GIVE ME ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B.
SIX SIX FIVE GALLAGHER PAROLE
YOU DEFENDER PAROLE HEARINGS
.
MR GALLAGHER WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY I SEE YOU HAVE A. WE HAVE
A VISIT FROM THE OTHER HOUSE
SENATOR. YES SENATOR NIELSEN
IT'S MY JOINT CO AUTHOR OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY THIS
MORNING. AND I ALSO WANT TO
START BY SAYING I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT YOU AND
I HAVE HAD- WITH REGARD TO THIS
BILL- IN WITH REGARD TO
CRIMINAL JUSTICE- IN GENERAL- I
THINK DOES HAVE BEEN VERY
POSITIVE. I HAVE APPRECIATED
SOME OF THE BACK AND FORTH THAT
I'VE HAD WITH MANY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. AND.
JUST WANT TO SAY AT THE OUTSET
I THINK EVERYBODY INVOLVED-
WITH THIS BILL IN THE IN THE
ISSUES INVOLVED THERE IN
EVERYBODY HAS THE SAME MOTIVE
WHICH IS THE PURSUIT OF
JUSTICE- IN FACT I THINK WE
COULD POTENTIALLY EVEN CHANGE
THE NAME OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUSTICE.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S WHAT
EVERYBODY IS FOCUSED ON AND IN
IS IN IS SEEKING OUT AND TRYING
TO FIND THE RIGHT. THE RIGHT
WAY. AND THAT'S PART OF WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY THE. THE
INTEREST OF JUSTICE- WERE SHOWN
IN THE SUPREME COURT CASE OF
MILLER VERSUS ALABAMA. WHEN THE
SUPREME COURT HELD THAT IT IS
WRONG TO AND JUST TO LOCK UP A
JUVENILE OFFENDERS. NO MATTER
WHAT HEINOUS THEIR CRIMES MAY
BE TO LOCK UP AND THROW AWAY
THE KEY AND NOT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW
REHABILITATION NOT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY- A CHANGE CHARACTER.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT SUPREME
COURT CASE WE CHANGE LAWS HEE
IN CALIFORNIA IN THE INTERESTS
OF JUSTICE AND WE DID WE DID
PRIMARILY TWO THINGS. I WON
SAID THAT THERE SHALL BE. IS
FOR JUVENILES WHO WERE
SENTENCED TO LIFE WITHOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE. THERE
SHALL BE S. A HEARING. BEFORE A
JUDGE WE CAN SHOW WHERE SOMEONE
COULD SHOW THIS IS HOW I HAVE
CHANGED THIS IS HOW- MY
CHARACTER HAS BEEN IMPROVE THIS
IS THE THINGS I'VE BEEN DOING
TO GET BETTER THAT I HAVE SHOWN
REMORSE. FOR THE CRIME. THAT
WAS COMMITTED. WE ALSO
PROVIDED. A SECONDARY- REFORM
IS AUTOMATIC. PAROLE HEARINGS
AFTER TWENTY FIVE YEARS SERVE
FOR ALL PEOPLE WHO'D BEEN
SENTENCED TO LIFE WITHOUT
POSSIBILITY ROLE SO WE DID
THOSE TWO THINGS- WHAT MY BILL
DOES TODAY. THIS IS CLEAR. IT
DOESN'T ROLL BACK ANY OF THOSE
THINGS. IT DOESN'T CHANGE THOSE
TWO CONCEPTS AND OUR LAW. WHAT
IT ACTUALLY DOES IS MERRY THE
TWO THINGS TOGETHER. IT MARRIES
THOSE TWO CONCEPTS TOGETHER.
AND IT ALSO HELPS US ANSWER THE
QUESTION OF. THAT IS STILL
UNANSWERED. BUYER LAW WHAT
ABOUT SOMEONE WHO. WHO IN FACT
IS IRREPARABLY CORRUPT WHAT
ABOUT SOMEONE WHO IS A
SOCIOPATH AND HAS NOT CHANGED
AND THAT ALL THE EVIDENCE IN
THE FINDING SHOWS HAS NOT
CHANGED- I THINK WE ALL. HAVE
COMPASSION AND HAVE. AN
INTEREST ENSURING THAT THOSE
WHO HAVE CHANGE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE REHABILITATED.
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT THERE
THEY EXIST. THAT TRULY ARE
SOCIOPATHS THAT DON'T SHOW
REMORSE. THAT ALL THE EVIDENCE
TO PSYCHOLOGISTS WHO EVALUATED-
ALL OF THE PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
THAT HAVE DETERMINED THAT NO
THE INDIVIDUAL IS NOT CAPABLE
OF REHABILITATION. AND IN THAT
CASE WE DO NEED TO HAVE
PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
DON'T GET THE BENEFIT OF
AUTOMATIC PAROLE AFTER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. AND SO THAT'S WHAT
ERIC'S LAW. DOES. AND IT'S IN
MEMORY OF ERIC INGER BREAST IN
HEN WHO YOU WILL HEAR ABOUT-
YOU KNOW WHO WAS MURDERED IN A
VERY HEINOUS WAY. AND THERE
WERE TWO MURDERS. CASE ONE WHO
HAS SHOWN REMORSE AND IS IN THE
PROCESS OF PAROLE AND ONE WHO
HAS BEEN FOUND BY A COURT AFTER
TWENTY YEARS NOT RIGHT WHEN HE
WAS SENTENCED. BUT NOW TOWARD
YOUR WHO HAS BEEN FOUND TO BE
IRREPARABLY CORRUPT AND YET HE
WILL CONTINUE TO GET
INDEFINITELY AROLE HEARING
STARTING NEXT YEAR. IF WE DON'T
MARRY THESE CONCEPTS TOGETHER
IN THE PURSUIT OF JUSTICE. AND
THAT'S WHAT I SUBMIT TO THIS
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY AS I
SUBMIT MYSELF I SUBMIT THIS
BILL. UNDER THIS COMMITTEE IN
THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE- TO
MARRY THESE CONCEPTS TOGETHER
TO SO THAT WE CAN BETTER GET
OUT ALL OF THESE THINGS. AND
ENSURE THAT JUSTICE IS TRULY
SERVED. AND SATURDAY I HAVE
WITH ME MY JOINT AUTHORS
SENATOR JIM NIELSEN AS WELL AS
TWO WITNESSES. ERIC SISTER
DEVON THE MARTY. AND BRENT AND
FERAL FROM THE COLUSA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. YES
MR BUT I WILL BE VERY BRIEF BUT
I COME FROM THIS- FOR WITH THE
RATHER SIGNIFICANT AND UNIQUE.
PERSPECTIVE MANY YEARS I WAS
CHAIRMAN THE CALIFORNIA BOARD
OF PAROLE HEARINGS. AND I HAVE
PROBABLY READ MORE CASES THAN
NOT TOO MANY OTHER PEOPLE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA EVERY
TIME TO FIRST TIME PAROLE
VIOLATORS OF DEATH ROW INMATES
SEEKING. TIMES IN IT TRULY IS
ABOUT JUSTICE BUT JUSTICE. IT'S
NOT ONLY FOR THE ACCUSED AND
CONVICTED. THE JUSTICES ALSO
FOR THE VICTIMS VICTIMS NEXT
CAN AND INDEED FOR SOCIETY.
OFTEN SAY AS FAR AS VICTIMS ARE
CONCERNED. OF AGREE JUST CRIMES
VICTIM NEXT OF KIN. THERE'S NO
CLOSURE. THERE'S NO GETTING
OVER IT. EVERY HOLIDAY. EVERY
BIRTHDAY. EVERYDAY THEY REVISIT
THEIR SENTENCE OF GRIEF FOR THE
LOSS FOR. IN THIS LEGISLATION I
THINK BRINGS THE EQUITY AND THE
RESPECT TO THAT ISSUE OF
JUSTICE. FOR SOCIETY. THAT FOR
VICTIMS. THESE PARTICULAR KINDS
OF CRIMES WITH SEVERAL FOR
SIMILAR FACTUAL. CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE STILL OCCURRING. WE JUST
HAD ONE IN WEST SACRAMENTO I
DON'T REPRESENT THAT NOW THAT I
USED TO. I AM VERY FAMILIAR THE
CASE. AND THE GRANDFATHER OF
THE VICTIM. CALLED ME. TALKED
ABOUT HIS GRANDDAUGHTER AND HER
CIRCUMSTANCES. HE WHEN HIS
HEART AND HIS GRIEF WAS CALLING
OUT FOR JUSTICE. AND I ENTREAT
THE COMMITTEE TO FAVOR BUT
CONSIDER THIS BILL IN THE
FURTHERANCE OF JUSTICE. THANK
THANK YOU SIR YES YES. TOTAL
FIVE MINUTES OF WHERE YOU WANT
TO BREAK IT UP. EVERYONE HERE
FOR BOTH OF YOU SO SURE PLEASE
PLEASE GOOD MORNING- CURRENTLY
ELEVEN SEVENTY DUE TO PROVIDES
FOR RE SENTENCING HEARINGS TO
JUVENILE L. WHAT MURDER
CONVICTS. EACH OF THESE
HEARINGS ARE TIME CONSUMING
LABOR AND GIVE INVOLVED
SECURITY ISSUES AND ARCHER
MATIC FOR VICTIMS IN THE
COMMUNITY. EACH HEARING ALSO
HAS A RIGHT TO APPEAL. INCLUDES
THE COUNTY WE SPENT FOUR DAYS
IN ELEVEN SEVENTY DUE TO
HEARING. THE PREPARATION COVER
THE UNDERLYING CASE AS WELL AS
THE INMATES ENTIRE SEE FILE.
THE JUDGE'S DECISION HAS SINCE
BEEN APPEALED AND WE HAVE
MULTIPLE HEARINGS AND APPEALS
AHEAD. ALL THIS THIS PASSAGE OF
SB THREE NINETY FOUR WHICH IS
SUPPOSED TO REMEDY THESE
EXPENSIVE TIME CONSUMING
HEARINGS AND APPEALS. SB THREE
NINETY FOUR DOES NOT FIX THE
SITUATION IT ONLY ADDS INSULT
TO INJURY BY PROVIDING PAROLE
HEARINGS FROM THE TWENTY FOURTH
YEAR OF INCARCERATION. ONWARD
WITH NO GUIDANCE ON HOW MANY
PAROLE HEARINGS WILL BE
PROVIDED OR HOW FREQUENTLY.
VICTIMS AN AGENT TO UNDERGO FOR
HEARINGS UNDER ELEVEN SEVENTY
TWO AND TEN DOZENS OF PAROLE
HEARINGS GOING FORWARD. IF THE
LEAD JUST CONCERNED ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT ONLY THE WORST
OFFENDERS WERE SENSE TO L. WHAT
THEY WOULD PROVIDE ALL INMATES
WITH THE RE SENSING HEARING TO
ENSURE THE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
SENSES RECTIFIED. THIS BILL
DOES THAT. SB THREE NINETY FOUR
ELEVEN SEVENTY DO NOT. IF THE
LEGISLATURE WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY IN VICTIMS
RIGHTS IT WOULD MINIMIZE
HEARINGS IN GENERAL PER PERSON
SO DANGEROUS THEY WERE FOUND TO
BE INCAPABLE OF REHABILITATION.
THERE'S A LITTLE BENEFITS AND
GREAT HARM IN HOLDING DOZENS OF
HEARINGS FOR THE RARE JUVENILE
OFFENDER THAT SHOULD NEVER BE
RELEASED. THIS ACCOUNTS FOR
THAT SB THREE NINETY FOUR AND
ELEVEN SEVENTY DO NOT. THIS
BILL IS BALLOT IT PROVIDES FOR
JUST SENTENCING FOR ALL
JUVENILE UPS. N. MAINTAINS
MINIMAL HEARINGS FOR THE TRULY
DANGEROUS. SB THREE NINETY FOUR
WAS A CHEAP FIX FOR MILLER AND
MONTGOMERY. AB SIX SIX FIVE IS
THE PROPER FIX. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. IT GOOD MORNING
LET ME BE CLEAR WE BELIEVE IN
SECOND CHANCES WHEN DESERVED
ONE OF MY BROTHER'S MURDERS LEO
CAN SURE AS WAS GRANTED PAROLE
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
IT'S A DECISION WE ARE AT PEACE
WITH LEO ALWAYS MAINTAINED HIS
REMORSE FOR HIS PART. ORDER THE
SAME CANNOT BE SAID ANYTHING
RAMOS ZENI WHO AT SIXTEEN
PLANNED EXECUTED AND ATTEMPTED
TO COVER UP WHAT DID TO ERIC.
FOUR BLOWS IN FATAL STAB WOUNDS
INCLUDING A SLIP WROTE. BUT NOW
NATHAN'S LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE
SENTENCE IS CEASING TO HOLD
MERIT SIMPLY BECAUSE OF AGE HE
WAS GIVEN A RE SENSING HEARING
IN OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WHERE WE LISTEN TO HIM
TESTIFY THAT KILLING ERIC MADE
HIM FEEL POWERFUL. THE JUDGE
APPLIED THE ADOLESCENT FACTORS
OF TRANSIENT RASHNESS
PROCLIVITY FOR RISK IN ABILITY
TO ASSESS CONSEQUENCES AND
WHETHER THERE WAS EVIDENCE OF A
DIFFICULT UPBRINGING WITH
EXPOSURE TO VIOLENCE OR ABUSE.
HE FOUNDED NONE OF THESE TRUE
FOR NATHAN. HE CONSIDERED
NATHAN'S PRISON RECORD WHICH IS
RIDDLED VIOLENCE. HE CAN STE HE
STATED THAT NAY AND STILL
SHOWED NO REMORSE AND DAMAGE.
SHIN WAS POSSIBLE JUDGE LIKE
ALL I AM FOUNDATION TO BE
IRREPARABLY CORRUPT UP HELD HIS
SENTENCE THE SUPREME COURT
RULED THAT THE LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE SENTENCE MUST BE
RESERVED FOR THE RAREST
JUVENILE OFFENDER WHOSE CRIME
REFLECTS PERMANENT IN COURT THE
LADY THIS RULING ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT TYPE OF JUVENILE HOWEVER
RARE DOES EXIST. A LAWS MUST
IGNORE LIST ONE SIX AND SEVEN
HUNDRED DETERMINES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WHO COULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY THIS PETITION AND A BRIEF
ERIC'S LOT THE FAIR COMPROMISE.
YOUR. OR ANY OTHER IS TOWARD
THE BILL. NAME IN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE MY NAME IS JOHN COLLINS
AND I'M ERIC'S EVENT IN PLEASE.
THANK YOU MA'AM. HI THERE MY
NAME IS EMILY COLLINS I WAS A
YEAR OLD WHEN MY COUSIN ERIC
WAS MURDERED AND WERE BEGGING
YOU TO PLEASE PASS THIS BILL
FOR ALL OF OUR FAMILY. I THINK
THE MOTION SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU. HI THERE MY NAME IS
BRANDON COLLINS COUSIN OF THE
VICTIM I WAS SEVEN YEARS OLD
WHEN HIS LIFE WAS TAKEN AND
THIS HAS NEVER ENDED FOR AS
THREE OH DON'T FEEL IT JUST AS
MUCH. AND WE WANT TO. THANK YOU
CAN TAKE. MY NAME IS SCOTT.
ERIC IS MY NEPHEW I ANYONE IS
EVER SPENT ANY MOMENTS AROUND
ONE OF THESE TYPE OF MURDER SO
INDIVIDUALS WOULD UNDERSTAND
THAT THE UNIQUENESS OF THEIR-
THREAT TO. IDEA AND- IT'S A
GREAT BUT JUST PASSED BUT THE
FUTURE. AND ASSOCIATION
ORGANIZATION AND HIM PARTY
SPOUSE TO DEVON PARTY I SUPPORT
THE PASSAGE OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU SIR. EVER MARTINEZ FAMILY
MEMBER COLUSA COUNTY I SUPPORT
KIRK SAW THANK YOU MA'AM.
VALERIE INTERPRETATION I'M FROM
COLUSA COUNTY I AM ERIC INTO
BRITAIN'S MOTHER AND DEVON
LOMBARDI'S MOTHER I STRONGLY
STRONGLY. SUPPORT THE PASSAGE
OF ERIC'S LAW THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I AM MARY AND ALL FROM
COLUSA COUNTY AND I. PLEASE
HELP THE TO PASS THIS ON.
AMENDMENT BECAUSE- IT'S FOR THE
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITY AND
ALSO OF OTHERS THANK YOU MA'AM.
GEN ALL- ONE OF ERIC'S-
CHILDHOOD FRIENDS AND A LIFE
LONG FRIENDS OF THE FAMILY AND
I FULLY SUPPORT PORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR. MACKENZIE
MARTINEZ I AM A COUSIN OF ERIC
I AND I SUPPORT ERIC'S LAW
THANK YOU. THE SHOW GARNERED
I'M DEVON MARTY'S BEST FRIEND
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT ERIC'S
HALL THANK YOU. ON ALL AND I'M
FROM COLUSA COUNTY FAMILY
FRIEND. AND I CAN SAY THAT THIS
IS NOT ONLY AFFECTED THEIR
FAMILY BUT OUR FAMILY IN MANY
FAMILIES WE SUPPORT EXPLORED TO
THE FULLEST. THANK YOU.
CRISTINA VERA I AM ONE OF
ERIC'S BEST FRIENDS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS LAW.
THANK YOU. CASEY RYAN- ONE
ERRORS- REALLY GOOD FRIENDS AND
I SUPPORT THIS LAW THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TYLER COLLINS- ERIC
WAS MY COUSIN AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS LAW. MY NAME IS
CHELSEA GRAB THEM FROM ALPINE
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
ERIC'S LAW. MELISSA HOFFMAN I
RESIDE IN EL DORADO COUNTY AND
I FULLY SUPPORT ERIC FINING
URGE YOU TO DO THE SAME.
HARRIET SALERNO FOUNDER AND
CHAIR OF CRIME VICTIMS UNITED
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM.
SEVENTY LAMBERT SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND THEY SUPPORT THANK
YOU. VERONICA ESPANOLA.
CLASSMATE AMERICAN OF RIGHT
SAID AND VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WHEN MISTER RYAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT THE DEPUTY PROBATION
OFFICERS IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THIS SHERMAN
MY NAME IS GRANT WARD AN THE
PRESIDENT OF CBS ASSEMBLY OKAY
SURE SIMPLY BEEN OF ASSOCIATION
ALSO REPRESENTS THE PROBATION
CORRECTIONS OFFICERS AND
PROBATION SUPERVISORS FOR THE
COUNTY SAN WERE YOU KNOW. WE
SEND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OKAY
ANY OTHER IN SUPPORT. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. EXCUSE ME COULD. SO
THEY CAN SIT DOWN BUT THANK
THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING MORNING
MORNING. IT FIVE MINUTES WITH
EVERY YOUR RAY. CHAIRPERSON
JONES SAWYER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE HONOR
OF TESTIFIED TODAY. MY NAME IS
PAUL BOCANEGRA AND I'M HERE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
SIX SIX FIVE. I WORK FULL TIME.
AS A CERTIFIED DRUG AND ALCOHOL
COUNSELOR I AM THE CO FOUNDER
OF A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
REVOLUTION GROUP WHICH HAS
STATE AND LOCAL CONTRACTS. TO
WORK WITH TROUBLED YOUTH IN
JUVENILE AND ADULT INSTITUTIONS.
I HAVE BEEN APPOINTED AS A
COMMISSIONER SAN MATTEO
COUNTIES JUVENILE JUSTICE
DELINQUENCY PREVENTION
COMMISSION. I AM PROUD OF THE
WORK I DO TO MAKE SOCIETY
BETTER AND REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF FUTURE CRIMES AND
YOU VICTIMS. FOR I AM NOT PROUD
OF EVERY ONE OF MY LIFE BILL. I
HAD A TROUBLE FILL CHILDHOOD.
WITH AN ADDRESS OF YOUR ABUSE
AND NEGLECT. BY THE TIME I WAS
A TEENAGER I WAS FILLED WITH
PAIN AND ANGER. MISGUIDED GANGS
ULTIMATELY ON BEHALF OF THE
GANG PLAYED A ROLE IN A DRIVE
BY SHOOTING OF ANOTHER TRUCK.
TROUBLED YOUTH. AT THE TIME I
WAS BIRD MY OWN PAIN AND HAD NO
REAL UNDERSTANDING OF THE HARM
I HAD CAUSED. MANY YEARS LATER
AND UNDERSTAND IT. AND OUR LIVE
EACH DAY WITH REMORSE FOR MY
ACTIONS. I WAS CONDEMNED TO
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE. THE
SENTENCE VALIDATED WHAT I
THOUGHT OF MYSELF. THAT NO ONE
THOUGHT I COULD EVER BE A GOOD
PERSON. IN PRISON I WAS A- AND
ENTERED MY WHOLE LIFE. ASSAULT
RAPE AND MORE. I FOUND MYSELF
RIGHT BACK WHERE I WAS AS A KID
FULL OF FEAR. I DID WOULD HELP
SURVIVE IN THE PAST AND I
JOINED A GANG. AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY TWO I WAS SENT TO
PELICAN BAY STATE PRISON AND
PUT IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT. I
WAS A SOLID TO KERR IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT FOR MORE THAN TEN
YEARS. IF YOU HAD MADE ME
DURING THAT TIME. MAYBE YOU
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE WAS THE RIGHT
SENDS FOR ME. BUT INSTEAD
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB NINE IN
TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE. A LAW
THEY GAVE SECOND CHANCES TO
YOUTH LIKE MYSELF. THAT LAW
GAVE ME HOPE AND LET ME KNOW
THAT YOU BELIEVE THAT I COULD
CHANGE. I CAN OF HOW MUCH THAT
HOPE AND YOUR BELIEF IN READ
CHANGE THINGS. I WORK FOR YEARS
TO DRAMATICALLY CHANGED MY LIFE
AND BECOME THE PERSON I BELIEVE
I WAS MEANT TO BE. AND BECAUSE
OF SB NINE. AND BY THE GRACE OF
GOD I WAS PAROLED. TODAY I SAW
ON TO HOPE. THE HOPE THAT WE
WILL NOT MOVE BACKWARDS AS THE
STATE AND BEGIN THE INHUMANE
PRACTICE OF CONDEMNING YOUTH TO
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX SIX FIVE WOULD DO JUST
THAT. IT ELIMINATES THE AND IT
SENDS A MESSAGE THAT WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT OUR YOUTH CAN GROW
AND CHANGE I RESPECTFULLY URGE
NO VOTE. THANK YOU. TAKE YOUR
CHAIRPERSON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS JOSHUA GUNTER
JOHNSON I'M THE SURVIVOR OF
ATTEMPTED MURDER. I WOKE IN THE
MIDDLE RIGHT AND- DISCOVER TWO
PEOPLE BROKEN INTO MY HOME WHEN
WITHOUT A WORD ONE OF THEM
POINTED A PISTOL OUT ME AND
SHOT ME TWICE- BUT I THE
FORTUNE WENT MY GOOD FRIEND
PATCH CLIENT WAS SHOT. MURDER
AND ATTEMPTED MURDER AND GIVEN
LIFE WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE. TWENTY FIVE YEARS LTER
I STILL HAVE A THIRTY TWO
CALIBER BULLET REMAINS LODGED
IN MY NECK BETWEEN C. THREE AND
FORMER MY SERVER CERVICAL
VERTEBRAE SO. MANY INJURIES
WERE SEVERE BUT MY
PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT OF THE
CRIME IN YOUR LONG AFTER I
HEALED PHYSICALLY. THE TRAUMA
PROPELLED ME IN A DOWNWARD
SPIRAL I BECAME ADDICTED TO
OPIATES- WHICH BY WAS EXPOSED
TO THE FIRST TIME WHILE
RECOVERING FROM A GUNSHOT
WOUNDS. THOUGH MY USER VOTE WAS
INITIALLY FROM MY PHYSICAL
INJURIES I EVENTUALLY BEGAN TO
RELY ON THEM TO MEDICATE MY
PSYCHOLOGICAL INJURIES. I LIVE
WITH SURVIVORS GUILT AND
UNTREATED PTSD THAT I'M- MAPS
WITH THE USE OF DRUGS UNTIL I
MADE A DECISION TO GET SOBER
FOURTEEN YEARS AGO. WITHOUT
PAIN MEDICATION I WAS FORCED TO
ADDRESSING. THE ANGER I KERRY
TOWARDS INDIVIDUALS WOULD HARM
ME. FOR MY OWN BENEFIT I
DECIDED TO REACH OUT TO BOTH OF
THEM. AND WROTE LETTERS TO
INQUIRE ABOUT DURING OUR
SEPARATION AND WHAT THEY'VE
DONE WITH THEIR LIFE. ASIAN
SHOT RESPONDED IN A THIRTY PAGE
APPALL. GIVE ME SOME INSIGHT
INTO HIS CHILDHOOD TRAUMA
DEEPER MORE SINCE STEP TO TAKEN
TO TURN HIS LIFE AROUND WHILE
INCARCERATED I COULD SEE WAS A
CHANGED PERSON. NOT SUGGESTING
THAT EVERYONE CHANGES WHAT I'M
SAYING IS HOWEVER IS THAT
DURING MY OWN PROCESS OF GROWTH
I'VE LEARNED IMPORTANT TRUTH
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO CAUSE
TREMENDOUS HARM CAN BE HEALTHY
ADULTS AND HAVE A LOT TO OFFER
SOCIETY. THIS LED TO ME TO A
CONCLUSION THAT SENSE WITH LIFE
WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE PAROLE IS WRONG BECAUSE
IT IGNORES THE POTENTIAL FOR
CHANGE. I WILL KICK THINGS
EXISTING LAW IS THE RIGHT
APPROACH WHEN YOUNG OFFENDERS.
IT GIVES A SECOND CHANCE TO YOU
SENT LIFE WITH THE WITHOUT
PAROLE THE CURRENT LAW MANDATES
A LONG TIME PERIOD FOR CHANGE
TWENTY FIVE YEARS BEFORE THE
FIRST BILL. OR DID YOU JUST
WANT TO ZERO FOR. THE POOR
MEMBERS ARE EXPERTS IN MAKE. AN
INDIVIDUAL MUST SHOW THAT THEY
HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT COURSE
CORRECTIONS IN THEIR LIFE OR
THE BOARD NOT GVE THEM
CONSIDERATION. CHRISTIAN THE
PERSON THAT HARM ME IN MY CRIME
WAS NINETEEN AT THE TIME OF THE
INCIDENT AND HE DID NOT BENEFIT
FROM SB THREE NINETY FOUR BUT
DUE TO HIS TREMENDOUS CHANGE IN
THE WORK YOU DID WHILE THE CARS
RATED. HIM SENSE WAS COMMUNITY
YEAR OUR LAST YEAR. HE FOR THE
PROBE WERE NOT CANDIDATE HERE.
IN IN SUPPORTER OF IT HIM BEING
BOUNCER DOUBLE A PROCESS THAT
ACTUALLY HELP ME WITH MY OWN
HEALING. I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
SIX SIXTY FIVE BECAUSE- I HAVE
WITNESSED WHAT THIS BILL
INTENDS TO DENY INDIVIDUALS WHO
COMMIT VIOLENT CRIMES AT A
YOUNG AGE CAN MATURE INTO
RESPONSIBLE. AND PROSOCIAL
ADULTS THEY SHOULD NOT BE
CONDEMNED TO DIE IN PRISON. I
URGE YOU TO NO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE IN A GOOD. DESIGNER
JUST MYSELF HEIDI REMOTE FROM
ON THE U. S. C. LOS GRUPOS
CONNECTION JUSTICE PROJECT JUST
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER LEGAL
QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE ANY.
OKAY ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. MY NAME IS
STEPHEN JOSEPH WILLIAMS I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE WE ARE
OPPOSED BECAUSE THE LEGISLATION
THANK YOU SIR. A WOULD
ORGANIZATION. ELIZABETH CALVIN
FROM HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH AND WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AB SIX
SIX FIVE. MANY CHRISTIAN RANTS
COMB- I WORK WITH HEALING
DIALOGUE IN ACTION AS A FORMER
AWHILE BY OPPOSE. EIGHT SIX SIX.
MY NAME IS JOE QUALITY OF JAMES
I HAD EL WANT AND I'LL POST
THIS BILL THANK YOU. ADVERTISER
MY NAME IS STEPHEN GREEN I WAS
SENTENCED CELL WHOPPERS IN
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD. AND I OPPOSE
A. B. SIX SIX FIVE THANK YOU.
THE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS TAIWAN
WILSON AND AS A TEENAGER I WAS
COME I WAS SENTENCED TO LIFE OF
THE POLICY PRO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE A. B. SIX SIX. THANK YOU
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS CHARLIE
POTTER NONDA WAS SENTENCED TO
LIFE WITHOUT POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE AT TWENTY. I WAS
COMMITTED I OPPOSE THIS. THANK.
MY NAME IS JEFF HOW ARE THEY
JUST SIXTEEN HOURS SINCE TO
LIFE WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SIX
SIX FIVE. MY NAME IS RUBEN RUIZ
I WAS SENTENCED TO LIFE WITHOUT
THE POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE- I
WENT TO PRISON WHEN I WAS
SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD. THANK YOU
SIR. WHENEVER THE TOOL MAY I
ALSO DISLIKE ABOUT POSSIBLE TO
PEROT SEVENTEEN OPPOSED HIS
BILL. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
MARK SLAUGHTER I'M A
SUPERVISING ATTORNEY WITH THE
SACRAMENTO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE SUPERVISING AND
REPRESENTING JUVENILES I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS TOM
DILEMMA I'M A TAXPAYING CITIZEN
WHO SUPPORTS JUSTICE FOR ALL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MY NAME'S KEEP CHANDLER
I'M A FORMER LIFE PRISONER AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
MISS NEAR NORTH AND WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS I'M ALSO FOR
ME CARS WERE COMMITTEE MEMBER
WHO WAS SENTENCED AT EIGHTEEN
YEARS OLD TO LIFE WITHOUT THE
POLICY PEARL. I WAS TOLD BY A
JUDGE WITHOUT WAS NOT READ THE
BILL AND I. OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU MA'AM. MY NAME IS
REBECCA WEICKER. MURDER VICTIM
FAMILY MEMBER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL I WORK WITH RESTORE
JUSTICE THANK YOU. AND I
REPRESENT A R. C. I WAS A
FORMER LIFE FOR AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME'S
EUGENE DAY I'M WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY
NAME'S MORALIS SOME WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE IN THE CROP
ORGANIZATION FORMERLY FOR AS
WELL I STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL.
PLEASE ENTER NGUYEN PROJECT
REBOUND STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS MATTHEW VARGAS I AM
A JUVENILE L. OFFER A LIFE NO
PAROLE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL WE ARE THE CHANGED
THANK YOU THANK. HERALD BUT IN
PROJECT REBOUND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE BAIL. HELLO I'M TONY
WALLIN PROJECT REBOUND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MARCO GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL. SUPER
RALPH FOR THE PACIFIC JUVENILE
DEFENDER CENTER WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. ROBERT DE CAMP WITH THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL. RICARDO
LONDON A ACTIVE MEMBER OF A RC
I WORK WITH A TROUBLED YOUTH IN
OUR YOUTH TO FORTY FACILITIES
SACRAMENTO FORMER LIFE FOR I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
CHANNEL LINE I'M A RETIRED LA
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU. FRANKLIN PORTER THE
PROJECT REBOUNDED HUMBLE STATE
UNIVERSITY I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. MARADI HM ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE FOR
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. ALTHOUGH ROMERO LIFE
COACH AT THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND FORMER LIFE FOR
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME
IS DONNA RUSSELL ALAMEDA COUNTY
MY HUSBAND IS CURRENTLY SERVING
JUVENILE LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB SIX SIXTY
FIVE. YOU. HI MY NAME IS
JENNIFER RAMOS AND I AM A TAX
PAYING CITIZEN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME IS A
HUNDRED DELGADO AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. HOLLY MITCHELL
AUTHOR SENATE BILL THREE NINE
FOUR IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THE MAN SOUND OF ALL SOCIAL
WORK GRADUATE STUDENTS
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY
INTERNET ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND SYSTEM IMPACTED.
MY NAME IS MARK IS NO YES FROM
ANTI WAS SAID THE VISION
COALITION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL I WAS ONCE TO A
JUVENILE AT FIFTEEN YEARS OLD
WITH A LIFE SENTENCE. YEAH
THANK YOU. ALEXANDER MALEK WITH
THE STORE JUSTICE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SPELL. THANK YOU.
ANON CON EXECUTIVE RECTOR
RESTORE JUSTICE FORMER LIFE FOR
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS CHERISHED INDIA
WITH RESTORE JUSTICE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BALL.
MENDOZA KERN CHAIR OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
STATEWIDE AND MEET ON THE
COUNCIL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. JOANNE CHEER FELONY
MURDER ELIMINATION PROJECT AND
WE FIRMLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
PETRA HIMES I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CORY PEPPER WITH THE ENTIRE
CITIZEN COALITION FORMER LIFE
IN MADE AS WELL AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. I'M A MEMBER OF ANTI
RACISM I BELIEVE IN REPETITION
AND I OPPOSE BILL. MY NAME IS
HAVE YOUR STORY WITH YOU IN
DIALOGUE AND ACTION WE WORK
WITH FAMILIES WITH LOVED ONES
MURDERED AND WE WORK WITH-
YOUNG PEOPLE IN PRISON- SERVING
LIFE SENTENCES FOR MURDER AND
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
CANDACE CHáVEZ WILSON ORANGE
COUNTY ON SOME MEMBER OF FEEL
FAMILIES NAY TO AND EL WANT AND
CALIFORNIA COALITION WOMEN'S
PRISONERS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. CITYNET GREEN COFOUNDER
FUEL FAMILIES UNITED TO END
LIFE WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE I OPPOSE THIS BILL. I'M
FILAMENT AS WITH RESTORE
JUSTICE AND FORMER LIVE FOR AND
I ALSO OPPOSES BILL. I'M AFRAID
I'M A STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY
I'M SYSTEM IMPACTED I'M TWENTY
YEARS OLD AND I WORK WITHOUT A
BIGGER CENTER I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THE WORKER CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS I
WASN'T ALIVE I WAS COMMUTED BY
BROWN AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SCHEME WITH BELLA BAKER CENTER
GOVERNOR BROWN COMMUTER MY
SINCE LAST DECEMBER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. IMELDA WAIVER FORM
OUR YOUTH OFFENDER- I WORK FOR-
PILOT DOT COM AND TO COOK THE
GOVERNOR COMMUTED MY SENTENCE A
TWO YEARS AGO I'D STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THE. AND
WHILE BROWN FORMER YOU WHEN I
LIVE FOR WHO SANDERS WAS COMING
ABOUT GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN HI
OPPOSED WILL NOT WORK FOR
RESTORE CHEN. GREG FIDELITY
INITIATE JUSTICE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. EMILY HARRIS
OF THE ELEVATOR CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THE CHAVEZ WITH INITIATE
JUSTICE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING ANNA
IRWIN SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LINDA EVANS I'M A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS
AND ALL OF US ARE NONE. I'M
FORMERLY INCARCERATED AND IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
WE NEED OUR YOUNG PEOPLE FREE
TO BURN THANK AND BE ABLE TO BE
PART OF OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
RENT A ROOM. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS SAM WASN'T EXPECTED
DIRECTIVE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL. THANK YOU FOR.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MEAN
ELSTER ON WITH UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS AT UC BERKELEY AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. HELLO AND GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS LYNN MAKE A PENDERGRASS
ANIMAL FROM A CAR STRAIGHT A
STUDENT- WITH- UNDERGROUND
DOLLARS ALSO WHAT UC BERKELEY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS MELISSA HICKS AND I AM A
MOTHER AND A GRANDMOTHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS HASA ALAMEDA WITH CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS
I'M ALSO A MOTHER AND A
GRANDMOTHER I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK. GOOD MORNING
I'M SEAN ROLAND WITHOUT ROAD
PRISON PROJECT AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING GABRIEL
GARCIA POLICY ADVOCACY MANAGER
FOR YOU THE LIFE AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S ELIZABETH
FRASER I'M WITH SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE SURGE BAY AREA
CHAPTER IN THE AMERICAN FRIENDS
SERVICE COMMITTEE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS YOLANDA
LEDESMA I AM ORGANIZER WRESTLE
CON BALLY DEEPER. I AM A MEMBER
OF THE FAMILY DENIED TO EN EL
LAW AND ALSO PART OF THE
ORGANIZATION I DROP A LOT
COALITION. AND I HAVE A HUSBAND
WHO SERVING SENTENCE AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU MA'AM. WHO SHE IS. MY NAME
IS BEEN A BEHAR I'M WITH
SILICON VALLEY DEBUG AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARIA
MARTINEZ I'M HERE WITH SILICON
VALLEY DEBUG AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE CLIFFORD I'M ALSO WAS
SILICON VALLEY DEBUG FROM SAN
JOSE AND AS A SURVIVOR OF A
VIOLENT CRIME BY A YOUTH. I
HATE TO THINK THAT THE FIVE
YEARS LATER HE'S STILL IN
PRISON I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. COURTNEY HANSEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS PART OF THE JOB A LOT
COALITION HERE IN SACRAMENTO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. DIANA
BLOCK CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WOMEN PRISONERS IN THE DROP EL
OP COALITION STRONGLY OPPOSE
WITH CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WOMEN PRISONERS AND THE DROP A
WELCOME PAIN I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
FLOWER ALVAREZ FROM THE CITY OF
SAN MARCOS FORMERLY
INCARCERATED DIRECTOR OF THE
WHOLE ME UP PROGRAM AND WIFE OF
A JUVENILE AYE FOR STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. INTERNAL WITH
HOME ME UP HERE FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL. HELLO MY NAME IS MIGUEL
GARCIA WITH AT FIFTEEN I CREATE
A COMMITTED A SERIOUS HARM AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT ON TO ASK
YOU FOR YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S ANALLY ERA MY
BROTHER IS CURRENTLY SERVING
I'LL OP SENTENCE AND I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS REYES
JANA RACHEL ROACH- I'M WITH-
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR LIVING
AND LOCKED I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO DO THE SAME THANK YOU. HELLO
MY NAME IS. POLLUTION AND I
HOPE AB SIX SIX FIVE. THE
MORNING- ENEMIES CAN MIDDLE
SOME THE POLICY MENU FOR DAN TO
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN LA I
WAS ONCE TRIED AS AN ADULT FACE
TWENTY FIVE TO LIFE NONPARTISAN
MADE DOING A LOT OF STUFF. MY
COMMUNITY AND I'LL POST OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. RYAN
LOW ANTI RECIDIVISM WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE. MY NAME IS
FULL OF LESTER WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I'M IN
OPPOSITION IS AGO. MY NAME'S
CLIFTON GIPSON I'M WITH CAL
STATE LA AND I WAS ONCE
SENTENCED AS A TEAM TO LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE AND AYE OPPOSED
AB SIX SIX FIVE. THANK YOU. AS
NICK GREINER I'M WITH THEANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I AND I
OPPOSE AB SIX SIX FIVE. MY
NAME'S BILLY TANG ON WITH ANTI
RESUME COALITION AND OPPOSE A.
B. SIX SIX FIVE. HI MY NAME IS
GERRY KEEP THEM WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
STRONG HOLLAND AND I'M WITH
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION AND
OUR POLLS AB SIX SIX FIVE. AND
I WAS STUDENTS TO L. UP AS A
MINOR THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
ROXANA GONZALEZ I OPPOSE EIGHT
AB SIX SIX FIVE I AM WITH
FAMILIES UNITED TO A WALK.
MEANING I'M SUSAN NAGAOKA MY
SOCIAL WORK PROFESSOR AT
SACRAMENTO STATE AND I OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU. NINE YOU
LARA'S SACRAMENTO LIEU LACK WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS PAUL BRILEY ON WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND I'M IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. HI MY
NAME GENERAL THESIS ON WITH ALL
OF US AND NINE AND ALSO A
FOREMAN INCARCERATED MEMBER OF
A R. C. AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS WELL. THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA ROBINSON I'M
WITH- ALL OF US AND THEN IN
SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KAELIN DEAN WITH
THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR AT POLICY LINK IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A MILLION- BRIAN I
AM WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. NONE MY NAME IS
ROBERT WILLIAMS ON POORLY
FORMALLY INCARCERATED ON THE
ACTIVE MEMBER OF OUR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL. HI MY
NAME IS JAMIE CHUNG I OWN A
SOBER LIVING AND I'M AND- A. R.
C. MEMBER AS WELL AND I'VE SEEN
THE FIRST AND CHAIR OF THESE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS MARIAH WOULD GUESS I
AM A SURVIVOR OF VIOLENT CRIME
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS SUSAN
SCOTT I'M A RELATIVE OF AN
OFFENDER. I'M WITH HEALING
ACTION AND DIALOGUE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. MY NAME IS
COREY CHENEY RICE IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH THERAPIST AT THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS THAT WERE
LITTLE ON WITH CALIFORNIA'S FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT OPPOSE THIS
BILL. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS GERRY
SILVA I'M WITH FAMILIES UNITED
TO END EL WHAT I CAME UP FROM
LOS ANGELES TO STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB SIX SIX
FIVE. YOU MA'AM. HELLO MY NAME
IS EVE VANGELIS DEBRA JO AND
I'M A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH
FAMILIES UNITED TO ELIMINATE L.
LOP AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT WAS THE WAY OUR
FUTURE THANK YOU EVERYBODY HERE
WITH A KID AND ONE. MA'AM THANK
YOU. HI ANGELIQUE THE WILLIAMS
AND I AM WITH FAMILY UNITE AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. HELLO GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS RAYMOND AG ALARM
WITH PAUSE AND FAMILIES AND I
WAS A JUVENILE SENTENCED TO
LIFE IN PRISON- I DID TWENTY
SIX YEARS AND I'M HOME AND ALL
AYE OPPOSED THE BILL AND I.
BELIEVE THAT. A FIGHTING CHANCE
TO COME HOME THANK YOU. A ARE
MORNING MY NAME IS A WERE URBAN
PEACE MOVEMENT I CAME AWAY FROM
OAKLAND THIS TO TELL YA POSES
BILL BECAUSE KIDS NEED THE
CHANCELLOR I KNOW YOU WILL GIVE
ME ALL THE- I CERTAINLY. GOOD
MORNING STEAM THE MEMBERS THIS
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GEORGE
GALLERIES I AM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF COURAGE WE'VE DONE
FOR SORT OF YOU JUSTICE IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I'M FORMALLY
CAR SEATED OUR MISSION OF THE
ORGANIZATION IS TO UNLOCK THE
LEADERSHIP OF YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN DIRECT COMPETITORS
SOME BY THE SYSTEM TO DREAM
BEYOND BARS. AND WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL THING THANK YOU.
MORNING MY NAME'S OUT BORN
REPRESENT THAT NONPROFIT THREE
SISTERS GARDENS FROM ACROSS THE
RIVER AND PROJECT WITH
SACRAMENTO- POSE THE BILL
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD BE
CREATE MORE JOBS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE. OF EDUCATE DO NOT
INCARCERATE THANK YOU. MORNING
MY NAME IS JAMES MARTINA MEAL
BAR- AS A COLLECTIVE STRONGLY.
OPPOSES A. B. SIX SIX FIVE
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING ONE OF
THE S. I YOU- MY NAME'S DENMAN
THOSE I WORK WITH FALLS IN
FAMILIES A BASED OUT OF
STOCKTON AND NO WE STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ALEX JOE. I LIVE HERE
IN SACRAMENTO BUT I HAVE A
NEPHEW WHO IS INCARCERATED IN.
LANCASTER AND HE'S BEEN IN JAIL
FOR A LONG TIME DAMON. WHO YOU
ARE I'M ALEX JOE OKAY THANK YOU
AND YOU OPPOSE ABOUT I OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MIGUEL QUESADA AT
SIXTEEN YEARS OLD- SINCE IS THE
FORTY FIVE YEARS TO LIFE I WAS
RELEASED UNDER SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTY AFTER SERVING TWENTY
YEARS AND AYE OPPOSED. A. B.
SIX SIX FIVE. THANK YOU. HI I'M
TRYING TO CLICK ON YES AND I'M
WITH EVERY PIECE MOMENT FROM
LOCAL CALIFORNIA. AND I OPPOSE
SB SIX SIX FIVE BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT AS A SOCIETY WE
CANNOT THROW AWAY THE LIE SO
YOUNG PEOPLE THANK YOU MA'AM
STUDENTS THAT. BE INVEST VALUE
IN THEIR COMMUNITY CENTER
FUTURE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ASH. BLOW ON
WITH URBAN PEACE MOVEMENT AND
AYE OPPOSED AS AS SB SIX FIVE
THANK YOU AND- HI MY NAME IS
BONNIE COST SOME AND I'M FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I WORK WITH
COURAGE COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
SORT OF USE JUSTICE AND I WORK
WITH YOUTH EVERY DAY AND I
OPPOSE SB SIX SIX FIVE BECAUSE
ALL YOU. DESERVE A SECOND
CHANCE THANK YOU. HELLO DAMON
DOES A WITH CARS COMMITTEES
NINETY FOUR STORIES JUSTICE IN
EAST OAKLAND. NINETY IN
OPPOSITION EIGHTY SIX SIX FIVE
BECAUSE I BELIEVE YOUNG PEOPLE.
DESERVE A CHANCE TO SOCIETY
THAT THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REEVALUATE THEMSELVES. MY
NAME IS CHECK WITH HERNANDEZ-
OF COURAGE. AND I OPPOSE SB SIX
SIX FIVE. MY NAME IS AN IDEAL
VERY GUY I'M WITH COURAGE AND I
OPPOSE SIX SIX SB SIX IS FIVE I
BELIEVE WE ALL DESERVE A SECOND
CHANCE. WHEN I WAS ALL DAY
RIGHT NOW I'M A DREAM BE ON
MARS FELLOW FROM COURAGE IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
AB SIX SIX FIVE BECAUSE THE
DEFINITION OF INSANITY IS DOING
THE SAME THING OVER AND OVER.
AND IS OBVIOUSLY NOT WORKING.
EVERYBODY MY NAME IS THOUGHT
SHE LED THE OATH I'M A YOUTH
COMMISSIONER WITH THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE DELINQUENCY PREVENTION
COMMITTEE. AND ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND I A PULLS A. B. SIX SIX
FIVE. BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN
SECOND CHANCES LOOK AT ME NOW
HE THAT MAY SHAKE YOU MA'AM
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
RICARDO JIMENEZ- DREAM GUARD
BARLOW FELLOW FROM COURAGE IN
OAKLAND AND I OPPOSE SB SIX IS
FIVE THANK YOU SIR. EVERYBODY
IS A SUSE WHERE NO AND I'M ALSO
WITH COURAGE AND I OPPOSE- A.
B. SIX SIX FIVE BECAUSE IS ON
CONSTITUTIONAL. THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME'S KRISTINA- ALSO THE
COMMUNITIES UNITED WITH WHERE
THIRTY VIEWS JUSTICE AND I
OPPOSE AB SIX SIX AYE. THANK
YOU. THE RESPOND ONE ALSO WITH-
COMMITTEES UNITED FIRST ARE YOU
JUSTICE FROM OAKLAND IN AND I
OPPOSE A. B. SIX EXPECT THANK
YOU. KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. ONLY ST LOUIS OF THE
CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES A STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. I'M
FRANCISCO SEE IS FROM THE YOUNG
WOMAN'S FREEDOM CENTER AND I
OPPOSE. MY NAME'S ANGEL
RODRIGUEZ AND WHAT THE YOUNG
WOMAN'S FREEDOM CENTER AND I
OPPOSE. POLLUTION FREE FROM US
I'M JUST GONNA GO IS IN A
CENTER AND I OPPOSE. AND ONLY
PEAS FROM YOUNG WOMAN'S FREEDOM
CENTER AND I OPPOSES BUT- MY
NAME IS OUT HERE. UNITED TWO
AND L. WALK AND I OPPOSE AB
THICK THICK FIVE. HI MY NAME IS
BLANKA **** AND I'M A WIFE I
BET EL WHOPPER AYE OR CHIU NOT
TO VOTE FOR THIS LAW AND I'M
WITH FAMILIES UNITED TO AND
HELP. GOOD MORNING ALDEN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIAN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING HIGHLY GANTON FROM ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AS WELL AS
PROJECT REBOUNDED SACRAMENTO
STATE I OPPOSE THIS BILL. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS SELENACHEAP
AND I'M ON THE PUBLIC POLICY
TEAM AT THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS HERE AND WHEN WITH
ASIAN PRISONER SUPPORT
COMMITTEE IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB SIX
SIX FIVE THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS NIKKI AND WITH THE
SACRAMENTO YOUTH COUNCILS
SACRAMENTO HOMELESS ORGANIZING
COMMITTEE IN TWO CARS RIGHT
SACRAMENTO- AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. HELLO MY NAME
IS MARIA THIS ONE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. ALL
MELONES LORENZO SHAVER AND
STRONGLY OPPOSE. MORNING MY
NAME IS DANIEL JOHNSON FOURTEEN
DAYS AGO I WAS RELEASED FROM
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE SENTENCE I
STRONGLY OPPOSES. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S DANIEL
SILVA FROM SELF AWARENESS AND
RECOVERY AND WE TO STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. HI MY NAME IS
LINDA WHEN I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SPELL. THANK YOU. HI I'M LONG
WHEN I WAS BORN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO I'M EIGHTEEN YEARS
OLD AND I OPPOSES. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PORSCHE TAYLOR I
REPRESENT FOR THE FROM THE
INSIDE OUT INK WE WORK DIRECTLY
WITH CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
HOLLY WORN WHITE AND THIS IS
RESERVE QUITE. AND WE OPPOSE AT
SIX SIX FIVE. OUR VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND I
BELIEVE THAT IS THE END
ACCORDING TO THE SERGEANTS.
THEY WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. LIST
QUIRK. YES QUESTION TO THE
CHAIR. AS I UNDERSTAND THE
BELL- THE COULD CONCERN IS
FAMILIES HAVING TO GO BACK
REPEATEDLY- TO. NOT TO TESTIFY
ON AT PAROLE HEARINGS I DO HAVE
THAT CORRECTED AND MISTER
GALLAGHER. SO PERHAPS YOU COULD
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE IN TERMS OF.
IF SOMEONE HAS COMMITTED A
TRULY HEINOUS CRIME AND SHOWS
NO SIGNS OF REDEMPTION HOW
LIKELY IS IT THAT THE FAMILY IS
GOING TO HAVE TO GO BACK EVERY
EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO THREE YEARS
COULD YOU ADDRESS THAT MR
CHARM. ACTUALLY I DON'T. TO
DON'T KNOW I THINK IT'S UP TO
THE FAMILY MEMBERS WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WANT TO COME BACK EACH
TIME NO INTEREST IN IS- WHAT IS
THE REQUIREMENT- OF THE PAROLE
BOARD AND PERHAPS YOU CUT. I
DON SO THAT CRAFT GO I'M MY
PROJECT CONDUCTS PRO HEARINGS
ON BEHALF OF LIFE PRESENTED AN
IDEA THAT PRO CLIENTS AND HAS
DONE SO FOR MANY YEARS. UNDER
MARCY'S LAW. THE TYPE OF PERSON
YOU'RE DESCRIBING HAS
DISCRETION TO SET THEM OFF FOR
A NEW PRO HEARING FOR UP TO
FIFTEEN YEARS AND VERY OFTEN IT
PRO PROCESS WHEN WE SEE
SOMEONE. WHO DOESN'T SHOW
REMORSE HASN'T CHANGED
CONTINUES PILOT. I'M THERE'S
THAT OVER IS TEN OR OR EVEN
FIFTEEN YEARS SO THE FAMILY
WOULD BE COMING BACK EVERY
EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO HAVE TO. AND
GIVEN THAT- I WILL
UNFORTUNATELY MISTER GALLAGHER
NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY COULD I IT TO THE
CHAIR COULD I HAVE ONE OF MY
WITNESSES MAYBE RESPONSE AND AS
TO WHAT HAPPENED WITH PRO
HEARINGS BECAUSE I HAVE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE EXPERTISE IN THE CITY.
AS WELL CAN HELP IT MR.
QUESTION DEFINITELY WILL TAKE.
SO IT. YEAH WELL YOU SAID SO
WE'RE TALKING ANOTHER ATTORNEY
OR SOMEONE IF YOU'RE TALKING
PERSONAL FAMILY THAT'S ONE
THING BUT YOU WERE THIS IS A
TECHNICAL QUESTION ABOUT HOW MR
QUIRKS CONCERN IS THAT YOU ARE
BURDENED THE FAMILY MEMBERS A
BIRD COMING BACK EVERY
EIGHTEEN. OKAY OR THAT. YOU
COMING BACK EVERY EIGHTEEN
MONTHS OR- SIX MONTHS FOR
PAROLE HEARING AND ACCORDING
THIS WITNESS IS NOT AS FREQUENT
IS THAT SO WHAT I WANT FOR
SOMEONE WHO WHO THIS FAMILY
MEMBER DESCRIBED AS-
DEMONSTRATING REMORSE
IRREPARABLY CORRUPT CONTINUING
TO COMMIT VIOLENCE DO YOU HAVE
A DIFFERENT. UNDERSTANDING OF
THE PROCEDURE FOR VOTE AND WANT
FIRST OF ALL WHAT YOU HEARD THE
WITNESS SAY IS THEY HAVE
AUTHORITY TO DELAY IT UP TO
FIFTEEN YEARS RIGHT. WHAT I'VE
HEARD FROM COUNTLESS VICTIMS
GROUPS. ISTHAT THESE HAPPEN
EITHER EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO THREE
YEARS CONTINUOUSLY INDEFINITELY.
AND WHAT MY BILL IS SEEKING TO.
DO IS SAY IF THERE HAS BEEN A
DETERMINATION. THAT THE PERSON
IS A RAPPER ABILITY CORRUPT
THIS IS YEARS AFTER THEY'VE
COMMITTED DEFENSIVE TWENTY
YEARS OR MORE. IF THAT
DETERMINATION IS BEEN MADE THEN
THERE AREN'T THESE AUTOMATIC
REPEATED PAROLE HEARINGS
THERE'S STILL THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHOW ALL THE THINGS. YOU
KNOW THAT THE OPPOSITION IS
TALKING ABOUT THAT THERE HAS
BEEN CHANGES THAT THEY CAN
CONSIDER ALL THOSE FACTORS- AND
SO THAT THEY WOULD GET ELIGIBLE
FOR PAROLE AND ULTIMATELY
RELEASE. AND AS YOU CAN SEE
FROM THE COUNTLESS ABOUT A
WITNESSES HAVE COME UP HERE THE
POLICY IS IN FACT DOING THAT
MANY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN RELEASED
BECAUSE THEY'RE SHOWING THOSE
THING. WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL
WITH A VERY LIMITED GROUP OF
PEOPLE OUT THERE. WHO THE
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND- ALL THE
EXPERTS HAVE ASSASSIN SAID
THEY'RE NOT. CABLE
REHABILITATION THERE A
SOCIOPATH. AND SO THEY SHOULD
NOT BE AUTOMATICALLY GIVEN A
PAROLE HEARING BUT UNDER
CURRENT LAW THEY WILL. MAYBE
THEY'LL DO FIFTEEN YEARS BUT
MAYBE THE FAMILY WILL BE EVERY
THREE YEARS BROUGHT INTO A
PAROLE HEARING. BEGGING AND
PLEADING PLEASE DON'T RELEASES
PERSON SO TO DISCRETION IS
TOTALLY UP TO THE JUDGE. TO THE
PAROLE BOARD WROBEL IN THAT
CASE. HEY UP TO THE OPPOSITE
END UP HAVE YOU SEEN THIS
HAPPENED THAT- FAMILIES ARE.
WELL THIS IS A CLEARLY A- RARE
CASE I WOULD THANK- HAVE YOU
SEEN IN OUR PAROLE BOARDS
ASKING PEOPLE TO COME BACK
EVERY EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO THREE
YEARS IN THIS SORT OF CASE NOT
FOR PEOPLE WHO DOT FOR THE
RECORD GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT
THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY A
REFERRING TO WHERE THERE'S BEEN
A FINDING OF HIGH RISK OF. LIKE
OF RECIDIVISM PSYCHOPATHY YOUR
SKILL WERE RECESS AT OR
CONTINUED BUT PRISON NOT FOR
THOSE NOT FOR THOSE PEOPLE.
IT'S TRUE THAT AT THE PROBOARDS
LAW REQUIRES THAT OVER TO ME.
MUCH LONG WILL TAKE ONE TO MEET
THEIR VERY HIGH STANDARD. NOT
POSING ANY DANGER TO THE
COMMUNITY SO PEOPLE WHO ARE ARE
CLOSE TO MEETING THAT STANDARD
WHO ARE BY DEFINITION NOT A REP
OF THE CORRUPT MAY RETURN TO
THE PAROLE BOARD WITHIN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS OR THREE YEARS-
BUT BUT THAT'S NOT THOSE ARE.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE VERY
DIFFERENT FROM THE GROUP OF
PEOPLE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT-
AND THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY HAS
BEEN REFERRING TO. THANK YOU WE
ALSO HAVE A RECORD OF WE ALSO
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF THE FORMER.
MEMBER OF THE BOARD A PRESENTER
IS RIGHT HERE WITH US. THE
SENATOR- BUT MISSED CUT BY THE
DOG IN THE HOUSE. SO HE HAS A
LITTLE BIT OF EXPERIENCE ON THE
ISSUE AS WELL. THANK YOU. THIS
COUPLE HUNDRED OF THANK YOU I
AM. A HAPPY NEW YEAR AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY- I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS
THROUGH THE CHAIR- THE FIRST
QUESTION IS- YOU KNOW WHO
DETERMINES. IN THIS SCENARIO IF
SOMEONE IS. ARAB LEAGUE CORRUPT
AND HOW CAN THAT BE OBJECTIVELY
DETERMINED WITHIN A SYSTEM LIKE
OUR PRISON SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY IDENTIFIED AS BEING A
SYSTEM- RIFE WITH CHALLENGES
AND FRAUGHT WITH SOME FAILURES
SO THAT'S MY ONE QUESTION- AND
I ASK IT BECAUSE I ACTUALLY YOU
KNOW PASSED THE BILL TWO FOUR
TWO THAT IS WITH BIAS IN THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM- AND SO HOW IS
THAT TAKEN OUT. AND THEN THE
SECOND QUESTION IS- AS IT
RELATES TO THE HEARINGS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT YOU KNOW
IF THE POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE
IT'S NOT GUARANTEED PAROLE AND
SO THE POSSIBLE. ROLLING GOING
BEFORE A PANEL FOR A HEARING IS
ABOUT TO PROCESS THE NIPPLE
TAKING THIS A WHERE WE IN FACT
TAKING AWAY- A PERSON'S ABILITY
TO DUE PROCESS SO THOSE ARE MY
TWO QUESTIONS THE OBJECTIVITY
OF THE DEFINITION AND FOR MY-
PROCESS. IN THIS MAY BE. BUT
IT'S ALSO HAD EXPERIENCE BEAT
ON IT MIGHT HELPFUL ALSO SO HOW
DO YOU WANT TO PARSE OUT THOSE
TWO QUESTIONS- OF WELL ALL ALL
STARTED IN A CAN THAT MY
WITNESS TESTIFIES TO WHATEVER
DO YOU WANT HE WOULD LIKE
SENATOR WHO'S BEEN ON A PAROLE
BOARD THAT MIGHT HAVE SOME
EXPERIENCE ABOUT. HOW OFTEN IT
IS. TYPICALLY THESE HEINOUS
INDIVIDUALS LET ME LET ME START
WITH HER QUESTION WHICH IS- WHO
DETERMINES IT IT'S A JUDGE THAT
DETERMINES IT THAT'S HOW IT IS
RIGHT NOW. AT STATUS QUO. THERE
ARE RE SENTENCING HEARINGS THAT
ARE GRANTED TO EVERY JUVENILE
OFFENDER WHO IS WHO HAS BEEN
SENTENCED TO L. WHAT. AND WE
AGREE WITH THAT POLICY WE'RE
NOT DISAGREEING WITH THAT AT
ALL IN FACT IT WAS GOOD TO HEAR
A LOT OF THE OPPOSITION BECAUSE
WE REALLY DON'T DISAGREE. THIS
GENTLEMAN STORY IS AMAZING AND
IT'S IT IS THE FRUIT OF THAT
POLICY READ A PERSON WHO HAS
CHANGED HIS. AND HIS CHANGE AND
AS RECOGNIZE WHAT THEY DID AND
SHOWS REMORSE GETS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PAROLE AND BE
RELEASED RIGHT. BUT WHO MAKES
THAT DETERMINATION IS THE JUDGE
AND ARE I MEAN READING FROM MY
BILL. THEY LOOK AT THE
DEFENDANT'S FAMILY AND HOME
ENVIRONMENT INCLUDING CHILDHOOD
ABUSE OR NEGLECT FAMILIAL DRUG
USE OR ALCOHOL ABUSE. THEY LOOK
AT THE CIRCUMSTANCES THE AFFECT
THE EXTENT OF THE DEFENDANTS
PARTICIPATION. AND THE WAY
FAMILIAR OR PEER PRESSURES.
THAT YOU KNOW IN THE CASE OF A
GANG MIGHT HAVE PLAYED AND
PLAYED PLAYED A ROLE IN THAT.
THEY LOOK AT YOU KNOW THE AGE
OF THE PERSON IN THE THIS. YOU
KNOW HOW IMMATURITY YEAR IN
AND- PATCH YOU ARE CITY AND
FAILURE TO APPRECIATE RISKING
CONSEQUENCES. PSYCHOLOGY
INVOLVED IN THAT PROCESS I
DON'T TAKE AWAY ANY OF THAT.
ALL THAT HAPPENS IN A JUDGE
MAKES A DETERMINATION BASED ON
ALL THAT EVIDENCE IF THE PERSON
IS IRREPARABLY CORRUPTOR NOT.
NOT AT THE TIME THEY WERE SENDS
LIKE YEARS AFTER SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE WHOLE PERIOD OF
TIME. DEVON'S FAMILY JUST WENT
THROUGH ONE OF THOSE RE
SENTENCING HEARING. THE
DEFENDANT WAS FOUND AFTER
CONSIDERING ALL OF THAT TO BE
IRREPARABLY CORRUPT. SO WE'RE
JUST ST IN THAT CASE. DON'T
GIVE GUARANTEED PAROLE HEARINGS
IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU'RE GETTING
NOW I AGREE WITH YOU BUT DON'T
GIVE GUARANTEED PRO HEARINGS
AGO INDEFINITELY AND COULD BE
EVERY THREE YEARS. THAT HER
FAMILY GETS DRAGGED BACK INTO
THAT TO HAVE TO COME AND
TESTIFY AND TALK AND BE DRAGGED
THROUGH THE CRIME ALL OVER
AGAIN. WHEN THERE'S ALREADY
TERMINATION THAT HAD A WHOLE
LOT OF STUFF THAT WENT INTO IT.
THAT'S OUR ASKING FOR NOT
TAKING AWAY THAT UNDERLYING
POLICY WHICH I THINK WE ALL
AGREE WITH. WHICH IS THAT
PEOPLE DO DO THINGS WHEN
THEY'RE YOUNG. THEY'RE BAD
JUDGMENTS THAT ARE THINGS THAT
HAPPEN. THE OTHER MURDER IN
THIS CASE IS ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE. HE GOT DRAGGED ALONG
FOR THE RIDE. AND HE IS BEING
PAROLED AND HE'S SHOWN REMORSE
AND HE'S GET. THE FAMILY. IS
SUPPORT OF AN ACCEPTED
ACCEPTING OF THAT OKAY MISSED
CODE SO THAT'S I MEAN I'M JUST
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
AND I THINK A LOT OF THINGS GET
CONVOLUTED OUR POLITICS THESE
DAYS ARE SUCH THAT WE WANT TO
GET ON OUR RESPECTIVE SIDES IN.
AND CALL THE OTHER ONE DOING
THIS BUT LET'S LOOK AT WHAT IT
REALLY DOES IS MY POINT. AND I
THINK IT'S A REASONABLE REFORM
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
THE POLICY THAT EVERYBODY IN
HERE SAID THEY SUPPORT. DID YOU
DID YOU WANT TO ADD JUST- TO
YOUR QUESTION THAT THE JUDGE
THE CALL MILLER FINDINGS ANY
APPLIED EVERYTHING TO NATHAN
AND TAKE EVERYTHING INTO
CONSIDERATION ANYTHING SAT UP
THERE AND SAID HE ENJOYED THE
WAY IT SOUNDED LISTENING TO MY
BROTHER'S BONES CRACKED WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A VERY DIFFERENT
TYPE OF CRIMINAL HERE- AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THREE MORE RECENT SING HEARINGS
AS THE LAW STATES RIGHT NOW.
WHEN JUDGES AND APPELLATE
JUDGES OF ALREADY DETERMINED
HIM TO BE IRREPARABLY CORRUPT
SO ON TOP OF THOSE THREE RE
SENTENCING HEARINGS WE ALSO
HAVE THE INDEFINITE PAROLE
BOARD HEARINGS IT IS NEVER ENDS
WERE ASKING FOR A COMPROMISE
HOW CAN WE LIMIT THESE. FOR THE
USE. THESE RARE JUVENILE
OFFENDERS NOT THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE HERE TODAY WE BELIEVE IN
SECOND CHANCES BUT WE ALSO HAVE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE
THOSE WHO WILL NEVER SHOW
REMORSE THEY'RE INCAPABLE OF IT
PSYCHOLOGICALLY. AND THEY ARE A
CONTINUED THREAT THAT'S ALL
ERIC'S LIES TRYING TO ADDRESS.
THANK YOU. UNDER THIS LAW
MISTER BOCANEGRAWOULD ALMOST
CERTAINLY ASK THE QUESTION
BECAUSE I'M JUST SO I MEAN I
JUST WANNA MAKE NOTE RELIEF ON
YOUR RIGHT. DOZENS OF THE BANKS
NEXT- UNDER THIS LAW MISTER
BOCANEGRA ALMOST CERTAINLY
WOULD DIE IN PRISON THIS LAW.
REQUIRES THE DETERMINATION BY
THE JUDGE FOR EVERY JUVENILE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE TO BE
MADE AT THE OUTSET TO BE MADE
AT THE TIME OF THE CRIME WHEN
EVEN MILLER THE UNITED THAT THE
SUPREME COURT A MILLER SAYS.
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION AT THE OUTSET-
AND IN MOST ALMOST CERTAINLY HE
WOULD HAVE BEEN. FOUND TO BE A
REPLICA BECAUSE WHAT HOW DO WE
KNOW WHAT SOMEONE'S GOING TO
LOOK LIKE WHEN THEY'RE TWENTY
FIVE OR THIRTY OR THIRTY FIVE
THAT IS THE TEACHING. OF THE
SUPREME COURT CASES AND THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT CASES
AND. WHAT CURRENT LAW DOES IS
ALLOW SOMEONE THE POSSIBILITY
TO GROW AND CHANGE AND BE
INCENTIVIZE TO CHANGE AND THEN
KEEP PUTS. THE DETERMINATION OF
IRREPARABLE CORRUPTION MEANS
THE CURRENT DANGERS IN DAYS
GONE LEGAL STANDARD BUT IT'S A
REBEL CORRUPTION NO ONE WHO IS
A RAPPER THE CORRUPT. IS
RELEASED FROM A CALIFORNIA
PRISON THROUGH OUR PAROLE
PROCESS IT PUTS THAT
DETERMINATION IN THE HANDS OF
EXPERTS WHO SPEND HOURS.
QUESTIONING THE PERSON SEEKING
PAROLE EVALUATING PSYCHOLOGICAL
RECORDS FROM THE TIME THEY WERE
JUVENILES AND CURRENT
PSYCHOLOGICAL- DETERMINATIONS
MADE BY THE PORTABLE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN CORRECTIONS
EXPERIENCE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO MAKE THAT DETERMINATION. THE
REST THE RECIDIVISM RATE THE
VIOLENT RECIDIVISM RATE FOR
PEOPLE RELEASE WERE CALIFORNIA
PRO PROCESS IS AROUND ONE
PERCENT. SO WE'RE GETTING IT
RIGHT. THAT THAT THAT THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT THE MAN WHO TOOK
HER BROTHER'S LIFE AND THAT TE
RARE IF THERE'S THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ARE NOT.
RETURNING TO OUR SOCIETY
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA PROPOSES
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THEY EVER
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT. THE THAT COME CLOSE THEY
ANSWERING YOUR FIRST QUESTION.
YES THAT- DID YOU WATER PITCHER
SECOND SO WE GET WHILE THE
SECOND QUESTION MISTER CHAIR
HAD TO DO WITH DUE PROCESS AND
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THEY
HEARINGS ARE A FORM OF DUE
PROCESS AND SO TAKING THAT AWAY
ALSO IMPACTS ABILITY TO HAVE
SUCH A SOMEONE'S ABILITY TO
HAVE DUE PROCESS I ALSO WANT
TO- TO SHARE SINCE WE- ABOUT
MILLER V. ALABAMA THAT EVEN
SCALIA OPINED IN THAT. RULING
THAT FOR JUVENILE
REHABILITATION AS A PRIORITY
OVER PUNISHMENT BUT MY SECOND
QUESTION HAD TO DO WITH DUE
PROCESS AND IF THIS IS WOULD BE
COMPROMISING THAT. SO I AGREE
WITH WHAT- THE WITNESS JUST
SAID EXCEPT FOR THE WHAT SHE
SAID ABOUT MY BILL IS FALSE AND
I'LL JUST READ FROM THE BILL
AGAIN. THE COURT SHALL PROVIDE
A DEFENDANT WHO IS UNDER
EIGHTEEN YEARS OF AGE AT THE
TIME OF THE COMMISSION OF THE
OFFENSE FOR WHICH THE DEFENDANT
WAS SENTENCED TO LIFE WITHOUT
THE POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE. WITH
A RE SENTENCING HEARING
ACCORDING TO THE TERMS OF THIS
PARAGRAPH AND THE TERMS OF WHAT
I READ TO YOU EARLIER ABOUT ALL
THOSE THINGS THEY GET
CONSIDERED. SO SAYING THAT MY
BILL CLOSES OFF THIS
GENTLEMAN'S OPPORTUNITY
REDEMPTION IS 1100% FALSE. AND
IT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL DOES
AND I'M TIRED OF PEOPLE. NOT
TELLING THE TRUTH ABOUT THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL AND WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING I JUST I MEAN I
GET PASSION ABOUT BECAUSE YOU
BELIEVE IN REHABILITATION AND
WE SUPPORT THAT. WE'RE SAYING
THAT. IF AT THAT RE SENSING
HEARING WHERE THERE IS DUE
PROCESS ALL THESE HEARINGS ARE
DUE PROCESS IS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SAY LOOK. I HAVE CHANGED.
HERE'S WHAT I'VE BEEN DOING
HERE'S AND DO AND AN
OPPORTUNITY SHOW REMORSE ABOUT
THE CRIME. AS ONE OF THE
MURDERS IN THIS CASE AND I
DON'T WANT TO USE THIS CASE IS
THE ONLY ONE BECAUSE THERE'S-
MANY DIFFERENT SITUATIONS OUT
THERE. HE DID AND ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO CAME UP HERE.
AND TESTIFIED THEY HAVE THIS
ABILITY TO MAKE THAT SHOWING
INTO GET ULTIMATELY RELEASE.
ONLY IN THE CASE OF THE LAW.
THERE WAS DEVON SAID THE
LIMITED JUVENILE OFFENDER.
WHERE THEY FIND LOOK THERE'S NO
REMORSE HERE THIS PERSON IS A
SOCIOPATH. THEY'RE NOT CABLE
REHABILITATION THEN THERE WOULD
BE NO PAROLE HEARING AIDS THANK
YOU MISS AGO EARLY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IT YOU MAY
CLOSE HARD WAS THAT YOUR
CLOTHES. WELL I'M MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGENCE. AS YOU KNOW I
BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY IN THIS
IN THIS BILL. AND AGAIN I WOULD
JUST I WOULD REITERATE THAT I
DON'T REALLY THINK THAT
OPPOSITION AND MYSELF ARE
REALLY IN DISAGREEMENT IF WE
LOOK AT WHAT THIS ILL ACTUALLY
DOES AND I'VE SAID OPPOSITION-
NOTE. OVER THE PHONE A
CONVERSATION WE HAD THIS WEEK
I'LL I AM COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS BILL TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE THAT IT DOESN'T
DO THAT. IT REALLY TRULY IS
FOCUSED ON THE INDIVIDUALS WERE
TALKING ABOUT HERE. AND I WE
CANNOT DENY THAT THEY EXIST
OKAY WE'VE SEEN IT. WE HAVE
CERTAINLY SEEN IN THIS CASE.
WHEN WE SEEN A YOUNG DEAL ROUTE
WALK INTO A CHURCH IN
CHARLESTON. JOIN A PRAYER GROUP
WITH A BUNCH OF PEOPLE AND THEN
PULL OUT A GUN AND START
SHOOTING THEM. ONE WE'VE SEEN A
YOUNG JUVENILE HERE AND DAVIS
BRUTALLY MURDER AT A COUPLE IN
THEIR HOME. AND SHOW ABSOLUTELY
NO REMORSE THEY EXIST. WE DON'T
LIKE TO THINK THAT THAT'S THE
CASE AND NONE NOT WE WANT TO
BELIEVE IN REHABILITATION WHICH
WE DO BUT THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS
OUT THERE AND WE HAVE TO HAVE A
TOOL TO IDENTIFY THEM UNDER THE
CURRENT POLICY RIGHT NOW THEY
WILL NOT GET IDENTIFIED THEY
WILL AUTOMATICALLY GET A PAROLE
HEARING THAT'S THE THAT IS THE
CASE RIGHT NOW TODAY I'M JUST
TRYING TO PUT A SAFEGUARD IN
THERE THAT PROTECTS THE
UNDERLYING POLICY OF
REHABILITATION OF JUVENILE
OFFENDERS. BUT TRIES TO PROTECT
AGAINST THOSE WHO ARE TRULY A
DANGER. A LIMITED GROUP. AND I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
CONSIDERATION. AGAIN I JUST I
BAG OF THE COMMITTEE WORK WITH
ME I'VE AGAIN ELSE I'VE SAID
THIS BEFORE I'M A REPUBLICAN. I
CAN'T RAIL ROAD THIS THING
THROUGH. I WOULD I AM VERY MUCH
WILLING TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION
AND WHAT PEOPLE YOU HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT- AS WE MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD AND IF YOU WOULD
GIVE ME THAT SUPPORT TODAY HAVE
MY COMMITMENT TO KEEP WORKING
ON IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
I KNOW WE'VE- WE HAD SO
CONVERSATIONS EVEN- I MADE ONE
COMMITMENT TO YOU THAT THIS
BILL WILL BE HEARD. AND
HOPEFULLY TODAY I'VE AT LEAST
GIVING YOU YOU MET YOUR WORD ON
THAT MISTER JET BUT WORD ON
THAT- AT INTO OB I KNOW WE'VE
HAD SOME PHILOSOPHICAL. EVEN
RELIGIOUS CONVERSATIONS- BACK
AND FORTH ABOUT THIS ISSUE. OF.
TO THE FAMILY- I KNOW
SOMETIMES- YOU BELIEVE THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DON'T HEAR
YOU. I'M ONE THAT HAD HIS UNCLE
KILLED. STAFF SEVEN TIME IN
FRONT OF HIS CHILDREN. EVERY
LAST MEMBER OF MY FAMILY OF
THAT PART OF MY UNCLE BILL'S
FAMILY ARE NOW IN SUBSTANCE
ABUSE. OF HIS WIFE DIED OF
ALCOHOLISM AFTER THAT IS
INCIDENT. AND SO WHEN YOU SAY.
OR YOU BELIEVE THAT WE HEAR
APPEAR DON'T UNDERSTAND. THE
PAIN YOU GO THROUGH THE PAIN AN
ENTIRE FAMILY GOES THROUGH WHEN
SOMEONE HEY MISLI KILL SOMEONE.
YOU NEED TO. I JUST WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT WE DO. AND IT
SOMETIMES- I HEAR FROM THE
OTHER SIDE THAT WE DON'T WE
ACTUALLY DO AND SO- I WANT YOU
TO KNOW THAT DAD I KNOW DAT IT
DOESN'T START OR END WITH JUST
ONE FAMILY MEMBER OR PERMITS TO
THE WHOLE FAMILY. AND IN THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE THAT'S WHY
YOUR REPRESENTATIVE IS HERE.
THE SEARS. TO STAND UP FOR YOU
BUT ALSO TO LET YOU KNOW BOTH
YOU REPRESENTED LET YOU KNOW
THAT- THEY FEEL YOU'RE PAID AND
WHAT'S GOING ON. SO HERE'S MY.
MY DILEMMA AND MOVING FORWARD
AND I WILL COMMIT TO YOU THAT
WE DO NEED TO SIT DOWN. AND
TALK ABOUT THIS IN IN A IN A
SUBSTANTIVE WAY AND TRY TO GET
TO US A SOLUTION ONE. I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE- LAW ENFORCEMENT
IN THE MEETING WITH YOU ANY
ACTIVISTS IN THE MEETING.
BECAUSE ONE I WANT TO SEE WHAT
PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE.
I THINK I'VE TOLD STORIES. OF
WHEN I WAS IN CATHOLIC SCHOOL
AND I HAD- A RELIGION CLASS
WERE A NON GOT UP AND SAID
ASKED THE CLASS IN RELIGION
CLASS IF YOU DIED TODAY YOU
WANT TO HAVE AN- AND YOU LOOKED
UP AND YOU SAW ADOLF HITLER SIT
NEXT TO JESUS CHRIST AND MAYBE
IT'LL SMART BOARD FROM SOUTH LA
PM BUS TO AN ALL WHITE SCHOOL.
IN PLAINVILLE CONNECTICUT I
SAID I THINK I WAS IN THE WRONG
HAPPEN. AND THE NON POINTED OUT
WHAT IF. AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
MATTHEW. NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE.
TWENTY SIX WHO CAN BE SAVED.
AND WITH MANTISES APOSTAS IS
IMPOSSIBLE BUT WITH GOD. ALL
THINGS ARE POSSIBLE. WE. AS WE
LOOK AT THAT THE MOST HORRIBLE
PERSON IN THE WORLD BAR NONE.
BAR NONE IF IN MY RELIGION AT
THE TIME OF HIS DEATH. HE WAS.
REPENTED OF ALL HIS SENT. THERE
IS SOMEONE THAT WOULD SAY THAT
HE- COULD BE READING. WHO IS IT
AMONG US THAT SAID THAT THIS
INDIVIDUAL CAN'T BE READING NO
MATTER HOW HEINOUS. IS SO IN
YOUR TIMELINE. IT IS
PROBLEMATIC CUTTING OFF PAROLE
HEARINGS BECAUSE IN THIS TIME
SOMEBODY SAYS THEY CAN'T BE
REDEEMED OR THAT PERSON IS
IRREPARABLY OF DAMAGE THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S WANTING TO THE
REASON I WANT TO PULL AND EVEN
PROBATION HOW MANY PEOPLE DO
THEY DEAL WITH WHO HAVE GOTTEN
OUT TO THE SOUTH LIKE THE
SYSTEM ITSELF. IS WORKING. AT
AYE A NOTE MISSED CENTER
NIELSEN WAS ON A PAROLE BOARD
HE MADE SURE THAT NO ONE. GOT
OUT. THAT WAS STEP FIT THIS
DESCRIPTION- I KNOW MR CENTER
NIELSEN VERY WELL FOR. TO KNOW
THAT SO IT ALSO SEEMS LIKE THE
SYSTEM WORK SO I REALLY WANT TO
HAVE A DISCUSSION. IF THIS BILL
DOESN'T MAKE IT OUT I REALLY
WANT HAVE A TRUE DISCUSSION OR
HOW MANY HEINOUS PEOPLE ARE RE
WE CLOSE THAT GAP IF THERE'S A
PROBLEM. TO THAT'S- THAT SEEMS
LIKE TO. THAT'S A REALLY WERE
WERE TRYING TO GET TO. AND HOW
DO WE HOW DO WE FOCUS LIKE A
LASER. ON AND I DON'T WANT TO
PUT IN MEET NOT I HEARD ONCE I
WANT PERCENT YOU YOU MAY THINK
IT'S 5% BUT WHATEVER THAT
NUMBER IS. HOW DO WE GET TO
WHAT. THAT AND THAT'S ONE IT
INTO WHAT WAS TO QUIRK IS
CONCERNED ABOUT BURDENING
FAMILY MEMBERS A BIRDIE
FAMILIES FROM COMING BACK AND
FORTH. ON TO THE- HEARING AIDS-
WHICH I DON'T THINK WE I THINK
WE DISAGREED ON WHETHER OR NOT
IS THREE YEARS THREE MONTHS
EIGHTEEN MONTHS. SOME PEOPLE
BELIEVE IT CLOSE TO THE A
DECADE OR FIFTEEN YEARS BEFORE
THEY COME BACK AND WIN CAUGHT
BETWEEN GET SOME AGREEMENT ON
THAT AND I THINK- WORKING WITH
BOTH SIDES WE CAN GET IN A ROOM
AND MAYBE GET SOME STATISTICS
TO SHOW PEOPLE WHO FIT THAT
CATEGORY THAT WE ARE IN FACT
BERNIE PEOPLE TO COME BACK TO
OFFER WHICH I THINK IS ANOTHER.
KEY COMPONENT TO OF PUTTING IT
UNFAIR A BURDEN ON FAMILY
MEMBERS TO COME BACK AND FORTH
AND SO- UNFORTUNATE OUR
RECOMMENDED NO VOTE BUT I'M
ALSO GOING TO COMMIT TO YOU
LIKE I COMMITTED TO HEARING.
HAVING HERE TO HEAR THIS BILL
IS COMMITTEE THAT WE BRING
EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM. AND TALK
RELEASED ABOUT THOSE TWO ISSUES.
AND THEN MAYBE WE CRAFT
SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY PUT A
ONE DETERMINE THAT THERE IS A
PROBLEM. AND THEN WE CAN FOCUS
LIKE A LASER I DON'T MEAN TO
OVER SIMPLIFY BUT THOSE ARE
LIKE MIKE. MY TWO MAIN CONCERNS
WITH THAT. I APPRECIATE NAY
MOVED TO APPROVE. ON AB SIX
SIXTY FIVE GALLAGHER THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER. CHEN
SERRANO LACKEY. LACKEY I
BAUER-KAHAN DEEP DEEP I
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER NO QUIRK.
QUIRK NOTES SANTIAGO WICKS
WICKS NOW. THAT MEASURE FAILED
IN THIS COMMITTEE BUT IT DIDN'T
FAIL. OKAY THANK YOU CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE THAT COMMITMENT A
WILL AND WE WILL TAKE YOU UP ON
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBER. THANK YOU
I'LL WORK WITH YOU WITH WHAT
YES I NEED SOME INPUT FROM YOU
TO. OKAY. MR FLOOR DO YOU WANT
TO WAIT FOR FEW FEW PEOPLE.
DELETED EVERYWHERE. RIGHT
PRESENTATION OF. WAIT BE DOING.
OKAY SO YOU'RE ALLOWED TO FACE.
SO WE WORKED OUT SO
. OKAY WE
NOW THAT WE'VE CLEARED THE SHE.
A COUPLE WITNESSES TRYING HARD.
NOR ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE. THIS SEEMS TO BE
APPROVED. IT SCARES ME. SO. BUT
EVERYBODY. WE ALL GREW UP WITH.
HI WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTER
FLOOR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M SURE
YOU'VE HEARD A BUNCH OF TIMES
THEY'VE A HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO THE
CHAIR I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
FIVE OH THREE WHICH ALLOW
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS TO CARRY C.
C. W.'S WHILE ATTENDING
RELIGIOUS SERVICES LOCATE ON
SCHOOL PROPERTY ONLY AFTER
RECEIVING WRITTEN PERMISSION
FROM THE SCHOOL TWO YEARS AGO
INTRODUCED HIS BILL AFTER A
GUNMAN KILLED TWENTY SIX PEOPLE
AT A CHURCH IN TEXAS LAST MONTH
THE GUNMAN ENTERED ANOTHER
CHURCH IN TEXAS KILLING TO MORE
PEOPLE. BEFORE A VOLUNTEER
SECURITY GUARD TOOK HIM DOWN A
VOLUNTEER SECURITY GUARD THESE
TWO INTO THE SHOW THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ARM SECURE
THE DIFFERENCE IS THAT OUR
SECURITY CAN HVE IN PROTECTING
A PLACE OF WORSHIP ACCORDING TO
WASHINGTON POST STUDY 86% OF
PUBLIC SHOOTINGS PUBLIC MASS
SHOOTINGS TOOK PLACE IN A GUN
FREE SCHOOLS ON BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AD NINE AND TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX. AB FIVE WITH
THREE WAS IN IT IS FOR THIS
VERY REASON NOT EVERY RELIGIOUS
STATION CAN AFFORD TO HIRE
SECURITY I UNDERSTAND THAT A
RECENT BILL ESTABLISH A GRANT
PROGRAM FOR NONPROFITS THE
REALITY IS THERE IS ENOUGH
MONEY AND THERE WILL NEVER BE.
ENOUGH PROVIDE ONGOING SECURITY
COSTS. WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IN
THIS GROUP WINNERS AND LOSERS
AB FIVE WITH. MAJORED NERA
APPROACH FOR SOME OF
CALIFORNIANS SOFTEST TARGETS. I
WANT TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
THIS BILL HAS A NUMBER OF
SAFEGUARDS INCLUDING.
REQUIREMENT OF AN INDIVIDUAL TO
HAVE A CONCEALED WEAPON PERMIT.
WRITTEN APPROVAL FROM THE
SCHOOL SUPERINTENDENT OR
DESIGNEES. THE PERMIT ONLY BE
VALID FOR ONE YEAR. ON PUBLIC
SCHOOL GROUNDS. AND THE PERSON
IS ONLY ALLOWED TO CARRY WHILE
ATTENDING RELIGIOUS SERVICES.
THIS DOES NOT IMPACT EVERY
SCHOOL NORRIS EVERY SCHOOL
REQUIRED TO PARTICIPATE. AB
FIVE WITH WE WOULD SIMPLY
INSURE THAT CAN. CONGRESSIONAL
CONGREGATIONS OF ALL FAITHS
HAVE THE ABILITY PROTECT
THEMSELVES AS THEY SEE FIT
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY'RE
LOCATED. WELL MAINTAIN ABSOLUTE
AUTHORITY OF THE SCHOOL. GOT A
COUPLE WITNESSES HERE I'M IN
THE OFFICE AND TACKLES
SUPPORTED AND THE WITNESS. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LIZ THAT
MOSCOW AND I'M WITH THE LIBERTY
FIRST FOUNDATION. OUR
ORGANIZATION SUPPORT STRONGLY
AB FIVE OH THREE SPONSORED BY
HEATH FLORA. EVERY CITIZEN
DESERVES THE RIGHT TO WORSHIP
WITHOUT FEAR OF INJURY OR LOSS
OF LIFE. EVERY MOTHER AND
FATHER DESERVES TO BE. NOT IN
FEAR OF SENDING THEIR CHILD TO
SCHOOL. FOR THEY MAY LOSE THEIR
LIFE OR BE INJURED RECENTLY WE
HAVE THE EGREGIOUS ACTIONS OF A
MAN AND OUR CHURCH IN WHITE
SETTLEMENT TEXAS THAT SINCE THE
C. ENDED THE LIFE OF TWO
PARISHIONERS. IF IT WERE NOT
FOR THE TRAINING AND THE
FIREARM THAT MISTER JACK WILSON
HAD WE HAVE NO IDEA HOW MUCH
LOSS OF LIFE WOULD HAVE
OCCURRED THAT DAY. THE INCIDENT
WAS OVER IN A MERE SIX SECONDS
AND NOT ONE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER COULD HAVE MADE IT
THERE IN THAT TIME. NO ONE. IT
CONSIDERS THEMSELVES THE HERO
AND MISTER WILSON CERTAINLY
DOES NOT EITHER. BUT HE
CONSIDERS HIMSELF A MAN OF GOOD
VERSUS EVIL. UNFORTUNATELY WILL
NEVER GET THE CRIMINALS TO
SURRENDER ANY TYPE OF WEAPON TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT WHAT WE CAN
DO IS BE PREPARED. AB FIVE OH
THREE AMENDMENT SHOULD BE
TREATED AS A GOOD VERSUS EVIL
BILL. CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE
MOST RESTRICTIVE STATES TO
OBTAIN A CONCEALED WEAPONS
PERMIT I AM A PERMIT HOLDER
MYSELF DUE TO A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE INCIDENT. AND THE
PROCESS INCLUDES A HANDGUN
SAFETY COURSE APPLICATION
INTERVIEW WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT BACKGROUND
SCREENING SYNTAX AND SIXTEEN
HOURS OF TRAINING INCLUDING
LIVE FIRING AVERAGING OVER FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE DOLLARS.
THEN THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
CONTINUOUS PROPER NESS THAT WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE OUR OWN COST
UP TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
COURSE TO STAY PREPARED. I AM
HERE TO ASK YOU GRACIOUSLY TO
GRAB EACH CITIZEN THE CHOICE TO
BE SAFE AB FIVE OH THREE GIVES
TRAIN CITIZENS A CHOICE TO
PROTECT THEIR LOVED ONES I HAVE
A DAUGHTER THAT GOES TO CSU
FULLERTON. AND IT SCARES ME
EVERY DAY THAT SHE WALKS ON
THAT CAMPUS THAT WE DON'T HAVE
SOMEONE THERE THAT MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO PROTECT MY CHILD. I
URGE YOU TO PLEASE EVALUATE
THIS BILL AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF IT THANK YOU. USE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- HAPPY TWENTY
TWENTY- WERE HERE- HERE FOR
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT ALSO HERE FOR
GUN OWNERS A CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION ALSO ARE
INSTRUCTORS FOR WANT TO THANK
YOU TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND.
HOW WE GOT HERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE- FOR DECADES IF YOU HAD A
CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT IN THE
CITY CALIFORNIA COULD CARRY. ON
PUBLIC OR PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND
NEVER ONCE THAT I'M AWARE OF
THAT WE HAVE A CCW HOLDER THE
KASSON ISSUE. FAST FORWARD TO
TWENTY FIFTEEN WITH THE PASSAGE
OF AB SEVEN OH SEVEN THAT SAID
CCW HOLDERS ARE NOT A LOT OF
PUBLIC PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND LAST
THERE IS PERMISSION. AND THEN
PASSWORD AGAIN TWO YEARS LATER-
BECAUSE SOME OF THAT DISCRETION
WAS ACTUALLY ALLOWING CCW
HOLDERS TO CONTINUE TO CARRY ON
THE SCHOOLS- WE HAVE THE
PASSAGE OF AB FOR TWENTY FOUR
WHICH JUST IS A FLAT OUT BàN.
BUT ONE OF THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THAT BILL WAS CHURCHES. THERE
ARE CHURCHES AND OTHER
RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS THAT
HAVE PRIVATE SCHOOLS ASSOCIATED
WITH IT. OR WHEN SCHOOL NOT IN
SESSION OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS THEIR
MEETING THERE- FOR EXAMPLE THE
CHURCH THAT I TEND. IS NOW
UNDER SOME RENOVATIONS AND SO
THEY'RE MEETING AT A LOCAL
PUBLIC SCHOOL BUT BECAUSE OF
CALIFORNIA LAW YOU CANNOT HAVE
A CCW HOLDERS ON THAT SCHOOL
CAMP. OUT BRING MAJOR MAJOR
CRIMINAL PENALTIES- AND THERE'S
ONLY VERY VERY MINOR EXCEPTIONS
FOR. LAW ENFORCEMENT EXETER OF.
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL IS IT'S
VERY NARROW. AND IT'S SAYING
DURING THE TIME OF THOSE
RELIGIOUS SERVICES IF THERE'S
PERMISSION FROM THE SCHOOL OF
THE AUTHORITY THAT YOU CAN
CARRY AND SO THE CHURCHES CAN
THEN MAKE. IMPORTANT SECURITY
DECISIONS SO- IF YOU YOU KNOW
THE EXAMPLE OF TEXAS WAS USE
RECENTLY WHERE YOU HAD SOMEONE
ON SITE THERE WAS A VOLUNTEER
WITH THE CHURCH IT WAS ABLE TO
RESPOND TO A THREAT. IS IT THE
TODAY. LAWS ARE NOT STOP
ADMITTED FROM SEEING GUN FREE
ZONES. OR AREAS THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED. TO DID SPECIALLY WHEN
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT EVEN
ALLOWED TO CARRY IN THE FIRST
PLACE. AND SO- THIS IS JUST A
VERY VERY NARROW CARVE OUT FOR
THESE RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS.
DURING THE TIME OF WORSHIP. I'M
IN ALSO COMES DOWN TO PRIVATE
PROPERTY- ISSUE SOME OF THESE
ARE PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS OR
PRIVATE SCHOOLS. AND WE'RE
DICTATING HOW THEY CAN- MAKE
THEIR IMPORTANT SECURITY
DECISIONS AND SO. I THINK THIS
IS A GREAT BILL IT'S VERY
NARROW. IT LOOKS BACK AT THE
ISSUES FROM- EIGHTY SEVEN OH
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR
AND I REALLY ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT. T. THANK YOU
ARE ANY ANYONE ELSE TO SUPPORT
BILL. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S REBECCA
MARQUESS I'M REPRESENTING BRADY
UNITED AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE
WELL WE SURE THE AUTHOR'S GOAL
OF REDUCING GUN VIOLENCE ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES DURING
RELIGIOUS SERVICES WE'RE SPREE
RESPECTIVELY DISAGREE THAT AB
FIVE OF THREE IS THE VEHICLE TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL LOOSENING
RESTRICTIONS ON CONCEALED CARRY
FIREARMS IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
OWNS IS CONTRARY TO THE NEED
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE
PROTECTIONS FOR CHILDREN YOUTH
AND THE COMMUNITY FROM GUN
VIOLENCE RESEARCH SHOWS IT
EASIER ACCESS TO FIRE ARMS
INCREASES THE REST THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH WILL BE INJURED OR
KILLED BY GUNS. MAKING THE
CONCEALED CARRY OF FIREARMS
EASIER AS A THREAT TO CHILDREN
SAFETY MANY SCHOOL FACILITIES
ARE USED BY CHILDREN FAMILIES
AND THE COMMUNITY AFTER HOURS
OR ON WEEKENDS YOU SPORT
LEAGUES ARE OFTEN HOLDING
PRACTICES OR GAMES CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES MAY BE USING THE
PLAYGROUND OR YOUNG CHILDREN
ARE LEARNING TO RIDE THEIR
BIKES ON THE BLACK TOP. EVEN
HIGHLY TRAINED OFFICER WHOSE
ONLY JOB IS LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE
ALL TOO OFTEN THEY FAILED TO
USE FIREARMS SUCCESSFULLY OUR
FOCUS SHOULD REMAIN ON
PREVENTING GUNS GETTING INTO
OUR PLACES OF WORSHIP AND
SCHOOLS RATHER THAN RELYING
CONGREGANTS TO PREVENT AND
SHOOT AT. I. RESPECTIVELY ASK
THE COMMITTEE WARNED ABOUT.
THANK YOU YES. GOOD MORNING
SANDRA BREYER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION- I ONE ALIGN MYSELF
WITH MISS MARKETS HIS COMMENTS
AND I JUST WANT TO ADD THAT-
PEACE OFFICERS AN ARMED
SECURITY GUARDS COMPLETE
TRAINING SPECIFICALLY TO
RESPOND TO EMERGENCY SITUATIONS
AND WE KNOW THAT MISTAKES STILL
HAPPEN- AND FOR SCHOOL PEACE
OFFICERS THAT ARE RESPONDING TO
A CRISIS SITUATION ON A CAMPUS
IF MULTIPLE PEOPLE HAVE A FIRE
ARM BUT IT'S TO MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO IDENTIFY.
WHO ACTUALLY IS SALTING THE
STANCE- WOULD CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION STRONGLY
OPPOSES THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ARE IS ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION. ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. A.
BACKUP POWER QUE HAN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I WILL ADD MY
HAPPY BIRTHDAY AS WELL SINCE
IT'S MY FIRST OPPORTUNITY- I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS INTENT HERE AS HE AND I
DISCUSSED I SAT ON THE BOARD OF
MY CONGREGATION RIGHT DROP MY
KIDS OFF SEVERAL TIMES A WEEK
FOR SUNDAY SCHOOL AND RELIGIOUS
SCHOOL AND- WE ALL KNOW HOW
SCARY THAT IS RIGHT NOW AND I'M
SO I SERVEDACTUALLY AS MY
SUNDAY SCHOOL SECURITY GUARD ON
SUNDAY. NOT ARMED AND. ASH AND
EVERYONE WAS SAFE WHEN THEY
LEFT IN RITUAL TO KNOW BUT YOU
KNOW I DON'T I JUST I. SHARE
THE CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION
THAT MORE GUNS DON'T MAKE US
SAFER. AND THAT- YOU KNOW
ALLOWING MORE PEOPLE TO CARRY
GUNS I NOT THE SOLUTION BUT WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
HOW WE GET GUNS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF PEOPLE WHO SHOULDN'T
HAVE THEM. AND ENSURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE AND I KNOW
THAT MY- MY CONGREGANTS SHARE
THAT. AND THAT. YOU KNOW I JUST
I APPRECIATE THE DESIRE TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE IN THEIR HOUSE OF
WORSHIP BECAUSE I KNOW I WORRY
ABOUT IT SEVERAL TIMES A WEEK.
BUT THAT AND THAT'S WHY I WAS A
HUGE PROPONENT WITH THE JEWISH
CAUCUS OF THE NONPROFIT
SECURITY GRANTS THAT WE- WERE
ABLE TO PASS THIS YEAR- THEY
WERE ZEROED OUT. IN THE BUDGET
THAT WAS INTRODUCED EARLIER
THIS WEEK AND SO I URGE US ALL
TO WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE WE
CONTINUE TO PROTECT THE SAFETY
OF. CONGREGATIONS OF ALL FAITHS
THROUGH THAT PROGRAM. BUT THAT
THIS IS NOT THE SOLUTION. YES
ANYONE ELSE. YES MISTER QUIRK
YEAH- WE HAVE VERY GOOD
EVIDENCE THE MORE PEOPLE HAVE
GUNS THE MORE OUR GUN DEATHS
THERE ARE BOB AND IF YOU LOOK
AT TEXAS VERSUS CALIFORNIA
FARMER GUN DEATHS ARE EVEN IF
YOU WERE TO BE ABLE TO PREVENT
A DEATH AT A SCHOOL THIS WAY A
YOU WOULD HAVE FAR MORE GUN
DEATHS IF WE WERE TO OPEN THIS
UP- YOU CAN EVEN SEE THAT FOR
EXAMPLE SAN FRANCISCO ON A PER
PERSON BASIS AS FEWER GUN
DEATHS. VAN THE RED COUNTIES
WHERE C. C. W.'S ARE GIVEN MORE
OFTEN SO I JUST CANNOT DO I
WILL NOT SUPPORT ANYTHING THAT
LOOSENS UP OUR- GUN CONTROL
BILLS. MR LACKEY. YEAH I THINK
I MIGHT HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO TRY TO BRING BALANCE TO THIS
DISCUSSION. THAT THERE IS
ACTUALLY A ROLE. FOR WEAPONS TO
BE USED AS DEFENSIVE.
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THAT IS
CLEARLY THE CASE THE SUN
AUTHORS TRYING TO PRESENT. GUNS
ARE. EVERYBODY WANTS TO
GENERALIZE GUNS IN THE ABUSIVE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND WE SHOULD PAY
ATTENTION TO THAT. BUT. EVEN
THE TERM GUN VIOLENCE IS
DISTURBING TO ME BECAUSE IT IT
FOCUSES ON THE WEAPON AND NOT
THE BEHAVIOR BEHIND IT AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S MISSING THE
MARK TERRIBLY AND I THINK WHO
CARRIES THE GUN. IS WHAT
DEFINES FOR THAT GUN AS A
THREAT OR WHETHER IT'S- A TOOL.
TO DEFEND THE INNOCENT. AND I
THINK CLEARLY WHAT WE HAVE
HERE. IS A PROCESS THAT'S BEEN
PROPOSED THAT WE WOULD. ASSURE
THE PEOPLE THAT WOULD BE
CARRYING THE GUN. ARE THERE TO
PROTECT THE INNOCENT. AND NOT
TO USE AN OFFENSIVE WEAPON I
CARRIED A WEAPON FOR TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS OF MY SIDE. LOADED
AND I WAS FULLY TRAINED AND IT
SAVED ME FROM HAPPEN TO USE
VIOLENCE IT SAVED ME FROM
ENGAGING IN A PEOPLE WHO WERE
ARMED. AND I'M TELLING YOU THAT
TO OVER GENERALIZE GUNS AS THE
DEMON. IS MISDIRECTED. IT'S THE
BEHAVIOR BEHIND THE GUN THAT
NEEDS FOCUS AND THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE
AND I COMMEND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. YOU. WITH COME UNDER THE-
I'M I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR- WANTING TO ENGAGE
IN A CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW TO
KEEP COMMUNITIES SAFE- I DO
ALSO AGREE HOWEVER WITH- THE
OPPOSITION AND SOME OF MY
FELLOW COLLEAGUES ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE DíAS- IN
SOME FORM OR ANOTHER. FOR ME
THE QUESTIONS- BEHIND THIS
BILL. OUR OUR MINI ONE- SORT OF
CHALLENGING THE LIABILITY AND
WHO ACTUALLY HAS A LIABILITY ON
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS THERE THEN
ALSO BECOMES A QUESTION OF THE
SUBJECTIVITY OF THE PERSON
AUTHORIZING THE USE I MEAN. YOU
KNOW THE PEOPLE ARE WOULD BE
GRANTING THE AUTHORITY FOR
SOMEONE TO COME ON TO. MY
CAMPUS ARMED AND THEY'RE A
SUBJECTIVITY IN THAT PERSON
THAT SUPERINTENDENTS ABILITY TO
MAKE A DECISION OR
DETERMINATION AND IF- BIAS OR
SORT OF PROFILING CREEPS INTO
THAT AND THEN UNFORTUNATELY
IT'S JUST A VERY SLIPPERY SLOPE
FOR ME AND TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT PRIVATE
MILITIA. AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT IS INCREDIBLY SCARY TO ME-
AS A BLACK WOMAN AS A PARENT-
AS A WIFE- IN AS A NEIGHBOR-
MANY OF THE- HOUSES OF WORSHIP
THAT ARE RENTING SPACES ON OUR
SKIN IS. CUTER. COMMUTER HAVE.
BEEN IS THE OUT. IS THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THAT. AND
THE NEIGHBORHOOD IF THOSE-
HOMES OF HOUSES OF WORSHIP NO
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY
LIVING IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD AND
HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING OF WHO
MAY BE SPECIAL NEEDS ARE WHO
WAS A LITTLE QUIRKY AND THEN
YOU HAVE FOLKS WHO ARE
GUARDING- IN THESE- PLACES OF
WORSHIP NOT REALLY KNOWING THE
INTRICACIES AND THE NEW WANTS
OF THIS COMMUNITY. OUT WHO ARE
LOADED IN ARMED AND THEN BAD
THINGS HAPPEN SO FOR ME THEIR
JUST SO MANY QUESTIONS. THAT
THIS RAISES RATHER THAN ANSWERS
THAT I UNFORTUNATELY WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT. WITH THAT
YOU MAY CLOSE YOUR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR ALLOW THIS
BILL TO BE HEARD AGAIN I THINK
THERE IS A FUNDAMENTAL.
MISUNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE. YOU KNOW AND
I RESPECTFULLY HAVE TO
COMPLETELY DISAGREE WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON ON SOME OF THESE
ISSUES. BECAUSE A FIREARM. IN A
TRAINED INDIVIDUALS HANDS. IS
FAR MORE EFFECTIVE THAN WAITING
ON LAW ENFORCEMENT TO GET THERE
IN OUR AREA OUR RESPONSE TIMES
ARE ANYWHERE BETWEEN SIX. AND
NINE MINUTES BEFORE LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN GET THERE.
THERE'S A LOT OF DAMAGE THAT
CAN BE DONE. WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE. IS A CHURCH.
CONNECTED TO A SCHOOL. THAT WAS
AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES I DO
BELIEVE OF THE PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION THAT WAS NOT
THOUGHT THROUGH. BECAUSE NOW
THAT CHURCH DOES NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY ALREADY PUT IN PLACE
SECURITY TEAMS DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PROTECT THEIR
CONGREGATIONS. SO WHEN THEY'RE
ALL FACING THE PEWS FOR THE
FACING THE PASTOR. THEIR BACKS
TO THE DOOR. AND THERE'S NOBODY
LOOKING OUT FOR. AND WE KNOW
THIS WORLD GONE A LITTLE CRAZY.
BUT I'M TELLING YOU RIGHT NOW
THIS BILL IS ONE OF THOSE BILLS
THAT CAN ABSOLUTELY SAVE LIVES.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S-
IT'S- STILL HARD FOR SOME MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE
OUT TO SUPPORT THESE KINDS OF
BILLS. BUT THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
BILLS THAT I FUNDAMENTALLY
BELIEVE. IF WE DON'T DO
SOMETHING SOON IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
AND THEN WE'RE ALL GONNA BLAME
THE GUNS AS OPPOSED TO ALLOWING
GOOD GUYS TO BE THERE GOOD GUYS
TO BE ON STAFF GOOD GUYS TO BE
ON SITE TO PROTECT THE CONTENTS
THE COMMUNITY WE ALL TALK ABOUT
WE WANNA DO EVERYTHING FOR
COMMITTEES TO BE SAFE HEALTHY
WE DO TONS OF LEGISLATION TO DO
THIS. BUT NOW WE'RE CREATING
SOFT TARGETS WERE ADVERTISING
TO PEOPLE WHO WANT TO DO PEOPLE
HARM. THAT WE CAN'T HAVE GUNS
AT THIS PLACE IF YOU WANT TO GO
AND PUT THE MOST DAMAGE GO
THERE. BECAUSE COPTERS SIX
MINUTES AWAY. WERE ADVERTISING
THIS WE'RE GIVING THEM JUST
FREE REIN ON US ON OUR
COMMUNITY. SO I'M JUST SAYING I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS HARD AND IS
THERE'S A REASON THIS BILL BEEN
HERE FOR THREE YEARS OKAY. AND
IT'S BEEN A GREAT DISCUSSION.
AND I WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR WE'VE WE'VE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT YOU KNOW AND IF
THERE IS ADDITIONAL TRAINING.
YOU KNOW IN ADDITION TO THE CCW
PERMIT HOLDERS IF THERE IS A
WAY THAT WE CAN GET INTO SOME
OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS I'M OPEN
TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION. BUT
IF WE DO NOT DO SOMETHING. IT'S
ONLY A MATTER OF TIME. AND
THERE'S DATA UPON DATA THAT
SHOWS WHEN GOOD PEOPLE HAVE
GUNS. BAD PEOPLE ARE STOP
QUICKER. AND THAT IS JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU- YES WE'VE HAD ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS AND I THINK THAT
THE AT THE. BUT THE CRUX OF IT
IS THE WHO. I REALLY IS TO END
UP AT A AT A THINK IT'S LESS.
THE WEAPONS THEN THE WHO AND
THE REASON I SAY THAT. WE'RE
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT HOW DO
YOU TRAIN THESE INDIVIDUALS
EVEN REPRESENTATIVE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER POWER QUE AND- IN HER
RELIGION AND WHERE THEY HAVE
PLACES OF WORSHIP THEY HIRED A
TAKEN A FOR SOME MANY OF THOSE
CONGREGANTS CAN AFFORD TO HIRE.
WELL TRAINED SECURITY OFFICERS
TO PROTECT THE CONGREGANTS.
WHICH IS WHICH IS HUGE. AND SO
I THINK I TALK TO YOU ABOUT.
FUNDS. MAYBE USE THOSE FUNDS
AND HOPEFULLY LAW ENFORCEMENT
NOT LISTENING BUT MAYBE EVEN
MAKE IT POST CERTIFIED. SO
THAT- EATING HERE THAT SO THAT.
THEY PROVIDE SOME COMFORT
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
BETTER READING THIS YOU HERE
AND EVEN MR LACKEY SAYS I'M A
WELL TRAINED INDIVIDUAL WITH
THE FIRE WE'RE NEVER GOING TO
QUESTION HIS FIREARM BECAUSE
IT'S IN HIS HAND WE DON'T
QUESTION LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ABILITY TO USE A FIREARM
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN WELL
TRAINED AFTER WELL TRAINED IN
USING IT APPROPRIATELY WERE
WERE OKAY WITH THAT AND SO.
THAT WAS KIND OF THE DISCUSSION
I WANT TO HAVE. WITH YOU ABOUT
HOW TO MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE-
ALL OF US ARE ARE. ARE NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH SOMEONE WITH A
FIRE OF BED IS NOT TRAINED TO
PROFICIENCY STANDARDS THAT WE
ALL IT HAS TO BE IS IT'S UP
HERE IS NOT JUST KINDA
EVERYBODY'S HERE AND WE'RE OKAY
NO WE'VE WE'VE GOT A UP LEVEL
BACK SO THAT- THAT CAN HAPPEN
DISCUSSION YOU WE WERE HAVING
HIS YOU KNOW WHERE YOU ARE.
THEY MAY NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD.
THAT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS THAT YOU MAY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT MAYBE THESE
GRANTS. CAN HELP WITH THAT AND
SO I WOULD LIKE TO IT DOESN'T
GET OUT OF THERE LIKE TO HAVE
THAT KIND OF DISCUSSION. I
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION WITH YOU BECAUSE I
MEAN ON THE TRAINING SIDE OF IT
I MEAN WE'RE ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO
ALL OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS
RIGHT AND THEN ALSO LOOK AT HOW
HOW LONG. I MEAN WE- COULD MAY
NOT. AS FOR SOMEONE STATE MAY
NOT HAPPEN OVERNIGHT. BUT IF WE
START TO TRAIN UP. INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE FEEL UNBELIEVABLY
COMFORTABLE. WITH TO BE ABLE
TO- SIT IN ANY CHURCH. AND BE
ABLE TO. ADD A PREREQUISITE
TRAINING BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE CHURCH AND IN
THE INCIDENT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT. NOT ONLY WAS IS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER THAT
TRAINED EVERYONE IN FACT I
THINK THE FIRST PERSON THAT WAS
SHOT WAS WANTED PEOPLE WHO
TRAIN- NIGHT HAVE A CADRE OF
PEOPLE. THAT ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DOING I SHOULD KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH A FIREARM. AND
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED THAT ONE
DAY YOU WILL NOT ONLY WILL YOU
SEE SOMEONE COMING IN. TO A
CHURCH A CIGNA CAUGHT OR
WHEREVER. AND INNOCENT PEOPLE
WERE KILLED BECAUSE THE PERSON
THAT WE THOUGHT. AT THE GUN A
GOOD GUY WITH THE GUN MAKES A
MISTAKE AND SHOOT ANOTHER GOOD
PERSON WITHOUT A GUN AND THAT'S
KIND OF WHAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE FEELING WITH SOME OF THE
SOME OF THE OTHER PEOPLE HERE
OF THAT WE DON'T ALSO DON'T
EXACERBATE THE SITUATION
BECAUSE SOMEONE IS NOT WELL
TRAINED. INTO A TEN
FORTUNATELY- BUT I DID HEAR
MOTION BY PRETTY SURE I WILL.
AT THE MOVE THE BILL. AN EIGHTY
FIVE A THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
NO LACKEY LACKEY I PARA CAN.
DEEP. DEEP NOT VOTING KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER NO QUIRK YOU KNOW
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO. WICKS. MAJOR
FAILS START IF YOU. MR MCCARTY.
AB EIGHT FIVE FIVE DEPARTMENT
JUST AS LAW ENFORCEMENT
POLICIES ON THE USE OF FORCE.
GOOD MORNING. IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE TO SAY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO EVERYBODY ELSE HAS
SO GO AHEAD YES IT WOULD BE IT
YES I THANK YOU- I KNOW I'M THE
LAST BILL HERE TODAY AND- YOU
KNOW YOU'RE NOT THIS BILL- ISHE
BUILDS UPON THE GREAT WORK THAT
THIS COMMITTEE LEGISLATURE DID
LAST YEAR WITH- AB THREE NINE
TWO AND SB TWO THIRTY THAT THE
USE OF FORCE A POLICIES WHICH
AS WE KNOW THE VERY END WAS A
BIPARTISAN EFFORT IT TOOK A LOT
OF WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT WE-
REFORM OUR PRACTICES REAP
RELATED DEADLY FORCE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THIS WOULD
WOULD WOULD WOULD BUILD UPON
THAT LINK JUST LIKE THAT A
STEP BACK HERE A YEAR AGO WE
HAD A FULL TWO YEARS AGO AT A
FLASHPOINT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WITH THAT FATAL- DEATH OF A
YOUNG MAN STEFAN CLARK WHICH
WAS ONE OF THE DRIVERS TO THOSE
BILLS WE PASSED LAST YEAR IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THAT OUR CITY
OF SACRAMENTO- POLICE
DEPARTMENT ASKED THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO CONDUCT A
REVIEW OF THEIR POLICIES AND
PRACTICES. NOT JUST ABOUT THAT
INCIDENT BUT THEIR ENTIRE
PRACTICE TO COME ABOUT WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS HOW DO EVOLVING
PROVE THAT DEPARTMENT INSTANTLY
WITH THE CHAINS BUT THE LAWS
BEING WITH. YOU BUT YOU KNOW
THE REALLY A GOOD POINT THAT WE
WANT TO BRING ABOUT THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE REST OF CALIFORNIA
SO THEY HAD AN AND NINETY SEVEN
PAGE REPORT RIGHT HERE WITH A
BUNCH OF RECOMMENDATIONS AND
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT A BRACE THE
BUNCH OF THOSE- SOMEWHERE IT
LIKE THE FLEEING FELON POLICY
WERE YOU KNOW WHAT YOU DO IN A
PRACTICE AND- FOOT PURSUITS
MAKES SPEAKING ABOUT PROMOTE
PUBLIC SAFETY BUT ALSO YOU KNOW
KEEP INDIVIDUALS AND
COMMUNITIES SAFER AS WELL. SO
WE KNOW THERE IS SOMETIMES A
NOT ALWAYS IT NOT TRAFFIC
COMMUNITIES FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
SO THIS ACTUALLY WAS THAT'S A
GREAT EXAMPLE OF WHAT CAN BE
DONE WHEN THAT PART TAKES A
STEP BACK AND SOMEBODY ELSE TO
MEN AND HELP TURNING OLD IT AT
A FANTASTIC JOB. STILL BE TODAY
IT WOULD BE LEE. I'M PROUD
THAT. THIS PROCESS. DO YOU TO.
TURN YOU GENERAL'S OFFICE TO DO
JUST THAT SO WE'RE WORKING WITH
THE ATTORNEY. OFFICE YOU WERE
WERE WORKING CONSCIOUSNESS BUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT- TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A PROPOSAL AS WE
GO TOWARDS TO THE SENATE. WHICH
WEEK THINK CAN BE EMBRACED BY
EVERYBODY BECAUSE WE ALL WANT
TO YOU KNOW MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER. AND HAVE
FEWER INCIDENCE OF DEADLY FORCE
AND I THINK THERE ARE SOME
SMART POLICE PRACTICES WITH
WHICH WE CAN BRING ABOUT. AND
WHAT THAT THE I'D THE NOTION
HERE IS WHAT A CITY WHETHER IT
SACRAMENTO OR- STOCK DINNER
MCFARLAND OR LOS ANGELES. YOU
KNOW TEY CAN GO TO ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND ASK THEM
HEY CAN YOU WORK WITH US TO DO
AN AUDIT OF OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENT PRACTICES AND COME
UP WITH RECOMMENDATIONS. HOW WE
CAN- MAKE MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES
SAFER BUT ALSO. A PROMOTE
PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. SO THAT'S WE
HAVE HERE BEFORE US AND LET ME
PRESENT MY FIRST WITNESS. GOOD
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS DENNIS
CLOSE TOMORROW WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AS A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED THIS BUILDS ON THE
GREAT WORK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DO THE U. OR SPELL. LAST YEAR
YEAH REALLY THIS IS UP TO
EIGHTY TO YOU KNOW GATHER DATA
AND PROVIDE BEST PRACTICES FROM
THE FORCE GEN CITIES THAT I
TAKE THAT. OPTION THROUGH THE
GENERAL ASSEMBLY STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THAT WE THINK THAT
UP YOU KNOW PROVIDING THAT
APPROPRIATE SPACE TO ALLOW
THESE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
TO. GET THIS INDIAN AND A
REVIEW OF THEIR YOU SUPPORT THE
POLICY A USE OF FORCE POLICIES-
WILL. BE BENEFICIAL FOR THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO WHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
SUPPORT BY THE. MARGOT GEORGE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
DANIEL GOOD TERRACE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. MR KERRY MEMBERS
RAINY PERRY WITH ERIN REASSESS
ITS OVER HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION ARBITRON PORAC WERE
IN OPPOSITION- WE AGREE WITH
THE WORK THAT WAS DONE LAST
YEAR WE ALSO TOOK- IN SB TWO
THIRTY ONE OF THE OTHER ONE OF
THE TO USE OF FORCE BILLS- WE
TOOK A LOT OUT OF THAT REPORT
IT WAS DONE BY ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND PUT IT INTO THE BILL IT IS
NOW YOU KNOW I'M STATEWIDE-
HOWEVER. THE BILL I WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR ABOUT THIS BILL
DOESN'T JUST SAY THE LOCAL
AGENCIES CAN GO TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO REVIEW THEIR
POLICIES AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE ARE OKAY
WITH THAT OKAY WITH WHAT
SACRAMENTO DID AND THEY WENT TO
WE WERE OKAY OUR LOCAL PEEL
AWAY SUPPORTED. AND LIKE I SAID
WE WORK A LOT OF WHAT CAME OUT
A REPORT AND PUT IT IN
LEGISLATION THE FIRST PART OF
THIS BILL SAYS THAT THE AG
SHALL DEVELOP A TASK FORCE. AND
IT'S IN THE I THINK CIVIL CODE.
SO IT'S IN THE CODE SECTION
THAT DEALS- WITH SETTING UP THE
CITIZEN. OR I THOUGHT THAT PART
WAS IN. IT WAS IT WAS AMENDED
BUT THE POINT IS A SET UP A
TASK FORCE OF WHICH WE ASSUME
IT WILL BE SIMILAR TO THE
RIPPER TASK FORCE OR SOMETHING
OF THAT. NATURE. I HAVE TO TWO
POINTS THAT NUMBER ONE. CALLING
IN A TASK FORCE TO PANEL WHO
HAS HAS WORKED TO ASSUME THAT
THAT TASK FORCE WOULD KNOWN
MORE ABOUT LOCAL GOVERNMENT I
MEAN NO BUT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAN THE LOCAL
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT FOLKS
THEMSELVES WOULD BE
QUESTIONABLE SECONDLY. WE HAVE
ALWAYS QUESTIONED. THE ISSUE OF
WHETHER OR NOT WHY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS BEING VIEWED BY THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BY THE AUTHOR
OF THE BILL. IS ALWAYS BEING
VIEWED AS SOMEONE WHO WOULD
KNOW MORE ABOUT LOCAL. LAW
ENFORCEMENT REGULATIONS AND
POLICIES THEN THE LOCAL
AGENCIES THEMSELVES. I JUST
WANT TO BE CLEAR AND SB TWO
THIRTY WHAT WE CREATED WAS
SUPPORTED BY BOTH HOUSES WAS A
MEASURE THAT WENT WAY FURTHER
THAN ANYONE ELSE IN THE COUNTRY
ON MANDATORY UNIFORM. POLICIES
WOULD HAVE TO BE CREATED.
HOWEVER THIS LEGISLATURE ALSO
AGREED. THAT WE HAD TO LEAVE
ROOM FOR LOCAL AGENCIES TO MAKE
THEIR POLICY IS THAT WORK FOR
THEIR AGENCY WHAT WORKS IN SAN
FRANCISCO OR BERKELEY DOES NOT
NECESSARILY WORK. IN OTHER
RURAL AREAS OF CALIFORNIA AND
I'M NOT TALKING THAT THEY CAN
GET AWAY WITH THINGS THAT THEY
WOULDN'T WANT TO. I'M TALKING
ABOUT JUST WAY THEY HANDLE
PUBLIC SAFETY FOR THEIR PEOPLE
IN THEIR AREAS AND THAT WAS
ALLOWED IN TWO THIRTY AND
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL WAS
DRAFTED THAT WAY. TO NOW HAVE.
BUDDY WHO WE DON'T KNOW THIS IS
NOT OUTLINED IN. WE IS SAFE
GOING AND STUDY JOSE MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND COME UP
WITH POLICIES THAT WOULD BE
THAT WOULD BE COULD BE
COMPLETELY CONTRARY TO WHAT WE
JUST DID LAST YEAR THIS TASK
FORCE COULD DO THAT THEY COULD
COME AND RECOMMEND WE RECOMMEND
THAT YOU COMPLETELY CHANGE THE
STANDARD. AND THAT WOULD BE
PASSED FORCE NOW GOING TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL COMING HERE IN SAN WE
RECOMMEND YOU DO ALL THESE
CHANGES WHICH WE- DID NOT DO
LAST YEAR THAT WE AGREED SHOULD
NOT BE DONE. SO THAT'S OUR
CONCERN WITH THE BILL AGAIN IF
THE INTENT IS TO ALLOW THE AG
TO DO WHAT THEY DID IN
SACRAMENTO AND THE AUTHORS
DISTRICT. WERE OKAY WITH THAT.
AND I DON'T KNOW I AND I. BY
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT I'VE
SPOKEN WITH. WITH OTHER GROUPS
WHO ARE NOT HERE TODAY. BECAUSE
THEY HAVE NOT THE END OF THE
AMENDMENTS HAPPENED LAST WEEK
SO WE WERE UNAWARE OF SOME OF
THE STUFF. BUT JUST SO I JUST
WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT. THAT.
SHARE ARRANGEMENT THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION I LIKE
THE ACTUAL COMMENTS OF MISTER
PERRY AND ALSO POINT OUT THAT
IT'S NOT JUST. A TASK FORCE TO.
TAKE A LOOK AT. AND BEST
PRACTICES OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. IT SAYS IT'S GOING TO
REQUIRE THE AG TO DEVELOP A
MODEL WRITTEN POLICY. FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK
TODAY ABOUT- THIS IS BUILDING
ON THREE NINETY TWO OR BUILDING
ON TWO THIRTY. WE HAVEN'T EVEN
HAD TIME FOR THOSE. STATUTES TO
REALLY TAKE AFFECT AND FOR US
TO NOW BE- CHANGING THAT AND
MAKING OTHER CHANGES THAT-
WOULD BURDEN THE AG'S OFFICE.
WHO WHEN THEY WEREN'T INVOLVED
IN A LOT OF OUR DISCUSSIONS AND
NEGOTIATIONS IS PROBLEMATIC FOR
US AND- WE THINK THAT IT'S A
GOOD IDEA TO ALLOW LOCAL
AGENCIES TO BE IN CHARGE OF
THEIR OWN POLICIES AS LONG AS
THEY COMPORT WITH TWO THIRTY
AND THREE NINETY TWO. IN THIS
ONE SET UP LIKE I SAID AT A
MODEL WRITTEN POLICY FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES BUT
THEY'RE ALL DIFFERENT- THE FOR
PRO ALLEGIANCE FOR EXAMPLE THEY
WEREN'T EVEN INCLUDED IN THREE
NINETY TWO OR TWO THIRTY. SO
HOW WAS IT EIJI GOING TO HAVE A
MODEL. A MODEL FOR THEM AND FOR
LOCAL COPS AND LOCAL THAT THE
SHERIFFS AND ALL THE DIFFERENT
STATE AGENCIES SO- WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND WE
THINK WE SHOULD LET- SB TWO
THIRTY IN AB THREE NINETY TO
TAKE EFFECT AND WORK BEFORE WE
START ADDING ON TO IT AND SO
THE RESEARCHERS SO STATION- IS
IT UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER ANYONE
ELSE PETITION. ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS YES WAS
COLORED OF TIME AT THIS I HAVE
A QUESTION TO THE CHAIR A MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THIS IS
OPTIONAL M. THE LANGUAGE THAT I
READING IT SAYS SUBJECT TO
AVAILABLE RESOURCES AND THE
DISCRETION OF THE A. G. SO MY
QUESTIONS ARE A IS THIS IN FACT
OPTIONAL AND BE HAS THE AG EVEN
INDICATED A WILLINGNESS AND
DESIRE TO DO THIS. THAT I DON'T
BLUFF GOOD YEAH. THE SECOND
QUESTION IS YES WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE THEY THEY WEREN'T READY
TO COME TAKE A PUBLIC POSITION
TODAY BUT THIS WAS THIS WAS
CRAFTED LAST YEAR THIS BILL IS
ALMOST IDENTICAL BILL. WITH
THEM AND- YOU KNOW WE'RE
WORKING IN CONJUNCTION AS FAR
AS THE RESOURCES YOU THIS IS A
BUDGET ISSUE AS WELL YOU KNOW
THEY DID THIS AMAZING REPORT
LAST YEAR FOR THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO BUT IT COST A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY AND-
WHEN THEY SAID AS WE LOVE TO DO
MORE OF THIS. IF WE HAD THE
RESOURCES AND SO THAT'S WHY
WHAT WE ARE HERE TODAY. THE
SETTING UP A FRAMEWORK OF WHAT
THIS WOULD LOOK LIKE. IN THE
AND WE WILL BE WORKING IN
CONJUNCTION AS FAR AS THE- YOUR
FIRST POINT QUESTION WAS ABOUT.
THE OPTING IN. THAT YOU KNOW
HER FAMILY CIRCLE YEAH YEAH
THIS YET AND I'M OKAY MAYBE
ADDRESS A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
THE OPPOSITION SAID SO I DO
CONCUR THEY RAISE UP SOME SOME
GOOD- POINTS THAT WE'RE WILLING
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION INTO
PREPARATIONS AND IN THE SENATE-
I'M VERY OPTIMISTIC SO I HEARD
A LOT OF POSITIVE THINGS THERE
AS WELL AS SOME CONCERNS- ONE
THING THAT I WANT TO DO CLOSE
BY IS. IS ABBAS LOOK LIKE WE
THOUGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WHERE THERE'S A MEETING OF
MINDS OF TWO TWO PARTIES YOU
KNOW THE YOU KNOW LIKE THAT THE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
JURISDICTION AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE MUTUAL AT TO
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS
SOMETHING WE WANT TO LOOK AT
OUR POLICIES HERE OUR BEST
PRACTICES LOOK AS FAR AS NOT
AGGREGATING WHAT'S HAPPENING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND- IN IN THIS
SPACE AND REALLY HELP A LOCAL
JURISDICTION WHERE. THERE'S
AGREEMENT GOING INTO IT FROM
BOTH SIDES. IF YES YEP- OF
COURSE HAVE A QUESTION- JUST TO
THE OPPOSITION- MISTER PERRY.
YOUR MAIN CONCERN AND GUY WAS
JUST THE- IT WAS SENT MAINLY-
THAT THEY WOULD MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS. OR WHAT
EXACTLY IT ARE YOU'RE A MMHM
PRECISELY YOUR CONTENT THE
FIRST THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THE FIRST PART OF THE BILL
RAINY PAIR OF PORK. AND HAVE
CHAU ARE ON THE FIRST PART OF
THE BILL A DEAL IS SET TO
CREATE A TASK FORCE AND IF YOU
READ AND HEAR WHAT IT DOESN'T
REQUIRES A TASK FORCE IS NOT
JUST RECOMMENDATIONS WAY SO
THEY SHOULD THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WITH THE HELP OF THAT
TEST FOR SHALL COME UP WITH
MODEL POLICY. AND THAT POLICY
COULD BE. MANY OF THE THINGS
THAT WERE IN THIS LEGISLATURE
TO AGREED NOT TO DO LAST YEAR.
IT COULD BE EACH COMPLETELY
CHANGING THE STANDARD. AT THIS
LEGISLATURE DID NOT PASSED LAST
YEAR IT COULD BE ANY STANDARD
IS DONE BY A TASK FORCE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND ARE
CREATING A MALL MODEL POLICY.
THAT WOULD COME BACK TO THIS
HOUSE. WE HAVE ALREADY DONE
WORK IN THIS AREA AND WE'RE
ALLOWING LOCALS RIGHT NOW TO
CREATE THOSE POLICY. RIGHT BUT
IT TO THE MODEL POLICY IT'S NOT
REQUIRED THAT ANY LOCAL ANTI T.
USE IT SAKARA ACT THE ARREST
AND MAKE THE BILL SAYS DEVELOP
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS SO THE
WHAT THEY WOULD DO AN ART AND
MY UNDERSTANDING. IS TAKEN IN
CONSIDERATION BEST PRACTICES
WHAT'S WHAT ARE HAPPENING
ACROSS THE STATE WE KNOW THAT
SAN FRANCISCO AND SEATTLE WERE
ALREADY DOING SOME INNOVATIVE
WORK ON- ON ON DEADLY FORCE AND
PREVENT AND PREVENTION. AND
THEN LOOKING AT THAT LOOKING AT
THE NEW POLICIES COMING FORTH
WITH. AT TWO THIRTY AND THREE
NINE TWO AND COMING UP WITH
KIND OF LIKE A BLUEPRINT OF HOW
CITIES COULD EVOLVE IN THIS
SPACE AND EVEN MORE SO THAT
THAT THAT THE REST OF THIS IS
THAT. MAYBE CITIES EITHER WE
HAVE CITIES ALL TYLER THAT ARE
COME UP AND SAY YOU KNOW WHAT
MAYBE WE'RE MISSING SOMETHING
AND SO THEY COULD GO TO THE-
ATTORNEY GENERAL. IT'S OFFICE
AND ASK THEM TO DO AN AUDIT AND
ASSESSMENT OF THEIR EXACT BACK
THIS IS HAPPENED HERE IN THE
CITY'S ACKERMAN ON THEY FOUND.
MULTIPLE THINGS THAT THAT THAT
THAT THEY MAKE CHANGES AND I
WOULD SAY THAT MAYES THINGS
WERE EMBRACED BY OUR LOCAL.
POLICE IN AS WELL SO WASN'T
ALWAYS ADVERSARIAL. ALL RIGHT
SO I DON'T SEE ANYTHING
MANDATORY- ABOUT THIS IN THE
SENSE THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO.
LOOK WE WERE VERY CAREFUL AND
IN FACT I IN THIS COMMITTEE
WHEN WE DID OUR LEFT THE- LET
THE BILL GO FORWARD WE SAID
SPECIFICALLY THAT THERE HAVE TO
BE CHANGES. AND THERE WERE
CHANGES AND I DON'T THINK THAT
WE WOULD JUST HAVE LONG ARM
ADOPT. ADOPT A RECOMMENDATION
BECAUSE IT'S MADE BY THIS TASK
FORCE SO I THINK THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT- CLARITY HERE- BUT
AGAIN IF THE AUTHOR WILL WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION AS HE SAID-
PERHAPS WE CAN MAKE THAT EVEN
MORE CLEAR THANK YOU. I HAVE
SOME SELECTIONS FIRST OF ALL. I
THINK THAT THIS IS VERY
TROUBLING AS IT STANDS RIGHT
NOW THERE'S JUST A LOT MORE
QUESTIONS AND THERE ARE
CLARIFICATIONS FIRST OF ALL. IF
I CAN ASK YOUR- BECAUSE IT'S
VERY VERY VAGUE. WHO'S GONNA BE
ON THIS TASK FORCE. YEAH. THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE CAME
UP WITH THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
LAST YEAR WHEN THEY WANTED TO
LOOK AT THEIR BEST PRACTICES SO
THEY WOULD BRING IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT THEY WOULD BRING IN
YOU KNOW POLICY EXPERTS THEY
WOULD BRING IN- ACADEMICS-
THEIR OWN DIVISION AND THAT'S
WE HAVE ASSURANCES TOLD THAT
THIS IS GOING TO BE A BALANCE
TASK FORCE BECAUSE WHAT WHAT
WHAT MY FEAR IS THERE IS A WILL
HAVE PEOPLE. THAT AREN'T
UNDERSTANDING THE ACTUAL
TRAINING THE GOES AND ALL THE
PARAMETERS THAT. LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE TAUGHT AND
THAT'S INTEGRATED IN THEIR
TRAINING. AND I THINK THAT THAT
THAT CREATES A PROBLEM AND
SECONDLY. I GET THE IMPRESSION
AND I DON'T SAY THAT THAT'S IT
YOUR INTENT BUT THIS COULD BE.
CONSIDERED ANOTHER BITE OF THE
APPLE YOU YOU ACTUALLY ON A
VERY VERY DELICATE. AND IT WAS
A HUGE ACCOMPLISHMENT TO
ACTUALLY GET AB THREE NINETY
TWO NSP TWO THIRTY- IN A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
EVERYBODY- CAME TOGETHER ON A
VERY VERY SENSITIVE VERY
DELICATE ISSUE AND I THINK THAT
THIS IS. A RE OPENING. A VERY
VERY- DIFFICULT SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES BEFORE WE EVEN
HAVE A CHANCE TO IMPLEMENT
THREE NIGHT TWO INTO THIRTY.
BECAUSE IT WHEN YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT. THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TASK FORCE AND THE
REVIEW THEIR SEPARATE. RIGHT
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE CLARIFIED.
OF. THE TASK FORCE IS NOT
OPTIONAL. IT'S MANDATORY AND
THE REVIEW IS OPTIONAL AND I'VE
I THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY
VERY DANGEROUS GROUND AND IT
PUTS THOSE OF US WHO. ARE
TRYING TO CREATE BALANCE AND A
VERY VERY. DELICATE VERY
DELICATE DISCUSSION POINT AND I
RESPECT BOTH SIDES OF THIS AND
OF COURSE I LEAN OF ARE
PROBABLY IN ANOTHER. CATEGORY
THAN MANY PEOPLE BECAUSE I'VE
ACTUALLY. BEEN ON THE OTHER
SIDE SO BUT I THINK WE REALLY
NEED TO BUILD. AND NOT. STIRRED
UP AGAIN AND I THINK OF THIS AS
A STRONG POTENTIAL TO DO THAT
VERY THING AND I DON'T THINK
THAT YOUR INTENT NOW AND BUT
BUT BUT I JUST HAVE TO TELL YOU
THAT I'M VERY VERY CONCERNED.
AND MAYBE MAC ADDRESS YOUR YOUR
QUESTIONS INCLUDES THOSE WITH
THREE WAYS- NUMBER ONE THEY ARE
TWENTY GENERAL'S THE TOP COP OF
CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S
HOW WE THAT'S HOW WE DO THIS
INDIVIDUAL IT'S A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. IT'S NOT-
YOU KNOW A CITIZEN APPOINTED
TASK FORCE OF MONDAY MORNING
QUARTERBACKS WHO HAVE THEORIES
BUT AREN'T INVOLVED IN THE DAY
TO DAY PRACTICE. NUMBER I'M
MORE THAN WILL WILLING AS WE
MOVE ALONG TO CLARIFY WHAT THIS
ENTITY SHOULD LOOK LIKE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH. THE ROCKS AND
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE IN A-
POSITION. SAY THEY DID. THE
MANY PART OF THIS WITH. THE
SACRAMENTO ABOUT IT IN A TALK
ABOUT HERE WITH. THE TASK FORCE
THAT THEY CREATED HERE. BUT YOU
KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE US
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE PEOPLE
THAT SERVED ON PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S TASK FORCE ON THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY POLICING-
THE POLICE CHIEFS FROM WATCHING
TO SEE IN PHILADELPHIA- YOU
KNOW THE- THE- THIS THE FORMER
SENIOR COUNSEL CHIEF COUNSEL
WITH THE LOOKS LIKE THAT. THE
UNION FROM. ILLINOIS ON THIS
ISSUE AS WELL SO. THE
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS WAR I THINK PEOPLE. THE
WITH WHAT YOU'RE ASKING WORK.
IN A DAY TO DAY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND NOT. YOU KNOW
PEOPLE COMING FROM FROM THE
OUTSIDE SO- AND AGAIN AS WE
MOVE FORWARD I WILL. WORK WITH
THE WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
DECLARE HI YOU KNOW WHO THE
PARTIES WILL BE. OKAY JUST SO
YOU KNOW ALTHOUGH AT THIS POINT
IT'S TOO BIG FOR ME TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THAT CAN TRAIN LIKE
IT THAT. FAIR ENOUGH. MR QUIRK
IN BRIEFLY I THINK YOU MAY BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION IF YOU SPECIFICALLY
SAY THAT THE MODEL POLICY MUST
BE CONSISTENT WITH EXISTING LAW
AND YOU MAY WANT TO ALSO ADD
THAT FOR THE RECOMMENDATIONS- I
WILL LEAVE THAT FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER. GOOD SUGGESTIONS. BUT
JONES. OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
YOU MAY CLOSE. THE NET I
APPRECIATE THAT THE
CONVERSATION AND SOME OF THE
SUGGESTIONS WE WILL TAKE THAT
FORD AND OUR GOAL THIS IS NOT
TO BE AN ADVERSARIAL POLICY BUT
TO BUILD UPON- THE GOOD WORK
FROM LAST YEAR AND TO HELP
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IMPLEMENT THAT AND
LOOK AT OTHER. PRACTICES IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT THEY COULD THEY
COULD HELP YOU KNOW BRING ABOUT
MORE PUBLIC TRUST TO
COMMUNITIES AND BRING ABOUT A
SMARTER POLICING OUT PRACTICES
AND WITH THAT ASK THE RIGHT
VOTE THANK YOU COULD- COULD I
ASK MR PERIOD TO COME UP. UP SO
THERE'S A COUPLE OF THINGS I'VE
HEARD- AS IT PERTAINS TO TRYING
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR. OF
WHAT MR QUIRK RECOMMENDED IS
THAT SOMETHING YOUR
ORGANIZATIONS. WOULD BE.
INTERESTED IN LOOKING AT IN
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR. WE I
SAID OKAY I'M NOT TRYING TO
COME IN ON OKAY. WE MET OUTSIDE
AND SPOKE OUR BIGGEST CONCERN
IS THE TASK FORCE BUT WE WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THE ATTORNEY ONE
AT A TIME TO START WITH. THAT
AND THEY WOULD TALK. EGGMAN
NATIONS AS THEY COME OUT. COULD
YOU REPEAT WHAT YOU JUST. YES
IF PHAM. FOR BOTH SIDES TO
CONSIDER OF THAT CERTAINLY THE
MODEL POLICY REFLECT CURRENT
LAW AND- PERHAPS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AS WELL
REFLECTS CURRENT LAW AS OPPOSED
TO GOING BEYOND CURRENT LAW- IF
THAT WERE THERE THAT WOULD
CERTAINLY- I HOPE BELIEVE SOME
OF YOUR CONCERNS THAT CAN
THAT'S UP TO YOU IN THE AUTHOR
TO WORK OUT. YES THAT'S ONCE.
THERE'S ANOTHER STEP ABOUT THE
TASK FORCE AND. BUT THE MISTER
LACKEY EXPRESSED SOME CONCERN
ANDWHAT THAT. OR COULD LOOK
LIKE WOULD LOOK LIKE BUSH
SHOULD LOOK LIKE IF WE WERE TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN. DO YOU WANT
TO BE ENGAGED IN THAT HAVE
DISCOVERED A WAY OF. THANK YOU.
AND THEN FOR THE AUTHOR I'VE
TRIED TO GET. THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SEVERAL TIMES. TO DO
CERTAIN THINGS AND HIS. IS
RESPONSE TO ME IS I WILL DO IT.
IF YOU FUNDED GROUP I WASN'T
ABLE TO FIND IT SO HE DIDN'T DO
IT. IF IT GETS OUT HIS
COMMITTEE AND IT GOES TO A
PROCS. I WOULD IMAGINE IT WOULD
NOT MAKE OUT OF APPROACH IF WE
CANNOT FUNDED. AND YOU'RE GONNA
NEED THE ATTORNEY GENERAL. THIS
ROUTE OF THE PART THAT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO GET
SOMETHING DONE. TO SAY THAT HE
WILL WHOLEHEARTEDLY EMBRACE.
AND IF YOU CAN GET THOSE TWO
THINGS IT WILL NOT GET OUT OF.
APPROPRIATIONS I CAN ALMOST.
GUARANTEE THAT IT IT WOULD BE
VERY DIFFICULT OR IF YOU GET TO
THE FLOOR THAT WILL BE A MAJOR
CONCERN FUNDING AND IF YOU
CAN'T BE FUNDED IN THE END OR
HE DOESN'T WANT TO DO IT. OR
HE'S- RETICENT TO DO IT IT
BECOMES VERY DIFFICULT EVEN
THOUGH HE'S THE TOP COP. IT
COULD BE VERY VERY DIFFICULT TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD AND- I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND VERY
CONCERNED. AND SO YOU HAVE. ONE
HURDLE. AT LEAST WORKING OUT
SOME LANGUAGE WHICH I THINK.
THE OPPOSITION AMENABLE TO- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK YOU'RE
HIGH HER. HURDLE IS THE FUNDING
AND SO- YOU NEED TO GET WORK ON
BOTH OF THOSE AT THE SAME TIME
AND THEN ANY OTHER AMBIGUITY.
IF BOTH SIDES WILL. AT LEAST
BRING IT UP- I HADN'T HEARD I
MEAN IN OPPOSITION HAD COME TO
MY OFFICE AND TALK TO ME AND SO
ON IN SOME WAYS I'M HEARING
THIS FOR THE FIRST TIME. AND SO.
I'M GOING TO HELP YOU GET IT
OUT A HUGE HOLE FOR GET OUT OF
HERE. BUT AFTER THAT I REALLY
NEED YOU TO. TO WORK TO THE
FIRM THIS UP AND GET SOME-
DEFINITIVE NUMBERS AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE SO THAT. THE
BILL. AS YOU'RE SAYING AS WHAT
MR LACKEY WOULD HOPE. THAT WE
ALL WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE THIS
SOMETHING THAT WILL HELP WHAT
EVERYBODY. WE SWEATED WE BLED A
LOT FOR THESE BILLS. OUR STATE
AGAIN WE BLED A LOT TO GET
THOSE BILLS OUT. AND WE DON'T
WANT ANYTHING TO UNDERMINE THAT
AN ARTIST AND DID EVERYTHING
FOR ME COMING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LOCAL CONTROL I
THINK THERE'S AN UNDERSTANDING
THAT. THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT DON'T HAVE TO ADD ON OF WE
NEED TO CONFIRM THAT UP TO. GET
DON'T HAVE TO BE. I THOUGHT YOU
WERE TRYING TO GET. SOMETHING
WHERE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COULD I
THINK THIS WHERE TO START IT
YOUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT DID NOT
DOES NOT. DO THINGS THAT YOU
THOUGHT WERE APPROPRIATE ROUTE
BUT IF THIS IS. SOMETHING THAT
PEOPLE CAN DO. IF THEY CAN MAKE
A DECISION THEY WANT TO DO IT
IF YOU'RE MEMBERS DECIDE THEY
WANT TO DO IT FINE IF THEY
DON'T WANT TO DO IS FIND IN. IS
THERE SOME CLARIFYING LANGUAGE.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THAT'S
PART OF IT SO WE- I KNOW THAT I
KEEP A LOT OF STUFF. ON THERE
THAT YOU NEED TO DO- BUT
HOPEFULLY IN A SHORT PERIOD
TIME IS YOU GOTTA GET TO
APPROACH YOU CAN YOU CAN WEAVE
THROUGH A LOT OF THAT. CONTRACT
MMHM. DO WE HAVE A MOTION. WITH
THE. ON A. B. EIGHT FIVE FIVE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER CHEN SWEAR I LACKEY
LACKEY NOPE BAUER-KAHAN DEEP.
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER HI QUIRK
QUIRK I SANTIAGO WICKS WICKS I.
THE BILLS ARE CALLED NEED ONE
MORE YEAH. YES. MR LACKEY. AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY. YOU MAKE MONEY
HE'S ONLY. ALL RIGHT WILL HELP
WE MR LACKEY WILL BE DEALING
TESTIFYING TODAY ON HIS BILL.
ON THE AMENDMENTS. BUT I'D BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T SAY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY MOON AND- EVERYBODY
ELSE DID NOT. IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE ALSO THAT I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE FACT IT'S YOUR
BIRTHDAY AND YOU DESERVED
CELEBRATE. THIS IS A BIG DEAL
TO ME. AND I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
ACTUALLY GENERALLY WORKING WITH
US ON THIS PARTICULAR MATTER.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT IS A
SUITABLE SOLUTION TO A PROBLEM
THAT PLAGUES THE PSYCHE OF
COMMUNITIES MY DISTRICT HEAVILY.
THIS LEGISLATION RESTORES LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY TO ENTER
DATA. INTO WHAT IS CALLED THE
CHILD ABUSE. CENTRAL INDEX
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS KHAKI. IF
FURTHER DEVELOPS A GRIEVANCE
PROCESS FOR AGREE PARTIES THAT
WISH TO BE REMOVED FROM THE
DATABASE. FOLLOWING THE DEATH
OF GABRIEL FERNANDES NOR
QUATTRO ANTHONY AVALOS THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON CHILD PROTECT.
I'M SORRY CHILD PROTECTION
RECOMMENDED TO INCREASE THE
COOPERATION BETWEEN DCFS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD AFFORD
INDIVIDUALS ACCESSING WHAT
COULD BE A DANGEROUS SITUATION
WITH THE WIDEST PERSPECTIVE
POSSIBLE. PART OF THE PROBLEM
THAT HAPPENED AND THESE OTHER
TRAGEDIES IS THAT WE HAVE
AGENCIES. THAT I JUST MENTIONED
WORKING WITH IN SILOS INSTEAD
OF COLLABORATION. AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY ESTABLISHES A GRIEVANCE
PROCESS CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH
HOWARD DSS HERE'S COMPLAINTS SO
IF YOU'RE YOU'RE IN THE SYSTEM
AND YOU FEEL LIKE IT'S UNFAIR
THERE IS A GRIEVANCE PROCESS
THAT'S BUILT BUILT WITHIN THE
US LED PROPOSED LEGISLATION.
THIS LEGISLATION IS A STEP
FORWARD IN ESTABLISHING A
WORKING SYSTEM. THE FORMER
DATABASE PROVIDED. I'M SORRY
PROVED TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEMS AND ISSUES WHICH WERE
HOPING TO ADDRESS RATHER THAN
RESTRICT. THE CAPABILITIES OF
OUR PEACEMAKERS. THIS BILL
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THE STATUS
QUO CREATED A CRACK. FOR THE
SENSITIVE CASES TO FALL THROUGH.
AND ALTHOUGH IT'S DIFFICULT TO
SAY THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
ELIMINATE THE CRACKS IN IT I DO
BELIEVE THAT IT WILL LIMIT THE
LIKELIHOOD OF THE TRAGEDIES
THAT HAVE LED TO THE DEATH OF
GABRIEL ANTHONY CANNELLA. AND I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
THIS LEGISLATION. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU I AM TEMPORARILY. THE
CHAIR HERE. I GUESS THE NEXT
THING TO DO IS ASK IF THERE IS
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO NO
WE'RE NOT EVEN DOING THAT OKAY
THEN THE NEXT THING TO DO IS TO
ASK FOR MOTION. ALL MOVE THE
BELL. ALL RIGHT. THEN WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND I MET. YEAH
DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE. PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS OKAY- I VOTED FOR
THE SAME BILL A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO AND ALL OF FOR IT AGAIN
TODAY AND I KNOW THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION IS ALSO AND I.
MADAM SECRETARY. ON AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER. LACKEY I'VE
LACKEY I BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP DEEP I
KAMLAGER. QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO WICKS. WICKS NOT
VOTING. THANK YOU IT'S ON CALL
NAY TWICE AND THE CHAIR WILL BE
BACK I'M SURE I THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT- WE NOW CAN GO TO THE
VOTE ONLY BILLS. THE FIRST ONE
HERE IS AB FOR A ONE FLORA
DRIVING DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE I MOVE THE BILL. ON
AB FOUR OH ONE FLOOR THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. LACKEY LACKEY I
BAUER-KAHAN BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP
DEEP I KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER NO
QUIRK NO QUIRK KNOWS SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS NOW. MEASURES ON
MEASURES ON CALL NEXT IS AB
FIVE EIGHT TWO. AND THEN IT'S
WHICH- YES- MISTER PATTERSON
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ON THE
AMENDMENTS TO AB FIVE A TO-
FELONY HIT AND RUN- AND I WANT
TO THANK MISTER PATTERSON FOR
BRINGING THIS TO US- BOTH I IN
THE CHAIR- LIKE THIS BILL AS
IT'S BEEN AMENDED THANK YOU
PLEASE AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR OUR- SUBSTANTIALLY MENDED
THE BAIL. PLEASE GO I HAVE A
FIRST OF ALL I'M AS CHAIR A
VICE CHAIR OF MEMBERS. I DO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR HELPING
US GUIDE THIS BILL ALONG. THE
VERSION YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU
DOES DO THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT WE OUGHT FOR THE BILL TO
DO WHICH WAS ESSENTIALLY CLOSE
A LOOPHOLE IN SORT OF CHANGE
THIS- KIND OF THIS PERVERSE
INCENTIVE TO HIT RUN KILL AND
LEAVE I WANT TO ESPECIALLY
THANK THE CHAIR YOU MISTER
QUIRK AND OTHER MEMBERS HERE
FOR HELPING US WORK. THROUGH
THIS. I ALSO WANT TO- THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA HE HAS A
JOINING US. AS A JOINT AUTHOR
AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON- AND I APPRECIATE THEIR
HELP AND ADVICE ON THIS AS WELL.
AS YOU KNOW A. B. FIVE A TWO
WAS NAMED AFTER GAVIN GLADDING
HE WAS HIT AND KILLED IN A HIT
AND RUN IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. HIS
WIFE SUSAN OFFERED POWERFUL
TESTIMONY MM MANY OF YOU I KNOW
REMEMBER THAT TESTIMONY AND I
BELIEVE THAT IT HELPED US TO
UNDERSTAND THE BILL AND HOW WE
NEEDED TO CLOSE THE LOOP ON HOW
WE COULD MOVE FORWARD
APPRECIATE THAT A LOT. WONDER
REITERATE MY GRATITUDE TO THE
CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS- THE GLIDING
FAMILY IS HERE AS WELL THEY
JOIN ME IN THANKING YOU FOR
MOVING THIS BILL ALONG
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS VERSION OF AB FIVE
EIGHT TWO. THANK YOU YES AND
THEN I WILL SAY THAT THIS IS A
CASE. WHERE WE WENT INTO IT
THINKING THAT. WE WOULDN'T
VOTE. FOR IT AND THEN
REALIZING. ARE EXACTLY WHAT YOU
SAID THAT IT IS IF YOU HAVE
BEEN DRINKING. IT MAKES SENSE
TO RUN AWAY RATHER THAN STAY
AND WE CAN'T ALLOW THAT THIS
ISN'T QUITE AS MUCH OF A
DETERRENT AS YOU WANTED- BUT I
THINK IT. WILL HELP SO WITH
THAT ALL I NEED A MOTION. OKAY
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON AB FIVE EIGHTY TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER LACKEY LACKEY AYE
BARRICADE HAN BARRICADE HAD I
DEEP. DEEP I KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER
NOT VOTING QUIRK HI QUIRK I
SANTIAGO. WICKS WICKS I.
MEASURE PASSES AYE GRADUATIONS
AND AGAIN THANK YOU AND THANK
FOR THE FAMILY AS WELL WE WOULD
DO THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT- THE FINAL BELL IS A
BE A DATE FOR BY MELENDEZ. IS
THERE ANYONE. TO SPEAK NOW OKAY
THEN I'LL JUST SAY THE CHAIR
AND I BOTH RECOMMENDED NOW
WE'VE JUST STARTED THIS. CHANGE
IN THE WAY WE DO- LIST I DO
THIS SEX OFFENDER LIST AND THAT
WE I DON'T THINK IT'S TIME YET
TO CHALLENGE. OF MADAM
SECRETARY DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
ON THE. MOVE IN A SECOND- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON EIGHT BE EIGHT EIGHT FOUR
MELENDEZ THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER. LACKEY LACKEY AYE
BARRICADE HAND BACK A HAND I
DEEP. DEEP I KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER
NO QUIRK YOU KNOW QUIRK NOTE
SANTIAGO. WICKS WICKS NO.
MEASURE IS ON CALL ALL RIGHT
WILL NOW- GO THROUGH UP FIRST
OF ALL- WE ARE EXPECTING THE
CHAIR TO RETURN SHORTLY. OKAY
HE SHOULD BE BACK MOMENTARILY-
IN THE MEAN TIME- WE CAN GO
THROUGH AND- GO TO THE. THE
OTHER MEASURES WHICH WELL FIRST
OF ALL WHAT DO WE DO. HI BUT
WHEN WE DO TAKE THE BILLS IN
ORDER RIGHT OKAY SO FLORA HOLD
HOLDEN. WHAT WE HAD IN THE.
OKAY WELL FINE I'LL GO AHEAD
AND TELL ME WHICH ONE IS. ON
THE CALENDAR. BAUER-KAHAN
BARRICADE HANNAH I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I. ON AB FIVE OH THREE
FLORA. BAUER-KAHAN BAUER-KAHAN
KNOWS SANTIAGO SANTIAGO NO
WICKS WICKS NOW. ON ITEM NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY SIX SIX FIVE
GALLAGHER BAUER QUE HAN
BARRICADE HAD NO SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO NO. ITEM NUMBER THREE
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL ON A.
B. EIGHT FIVE FIVE MCCARTY
BAUER-KAHAN. BARRICADE HAD AYE
DEEP. OF THE MCCARTY WOOD YES
SIR. NO DEEP NO SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB NINE OH
FOUR CHAO QUIRK HI QUIRK I
WICKS. ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR
EIGHTY NINE FOR. WICKS I. ON
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWELVE TEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW WICKS.
WITHOUT VOTING. ON ITEM NUMBER
SIX IS MEASURE WAS ON CALL AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY BY MR LACKEY
JONES SAWYER KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER
NOT VOTING SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI
THAT MEASURE PASSES. ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB FOUR ONE
FLOOR THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL
JONES SAWYER SANTIAGO. AB FAR
WHEN FLORA AT. ITEM NO. MISTER
CHAIRMAN ON A BEFORE ONE FLORA.
NO THAT MEASURE FAILED. ON ITEM
NUMBER NINE. AB FIVE EIGHTY TWO.
AT JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. ON
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB EIGHT EIGHT
FOUR MELINDA SAYS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL JONES SAWYER WHICH ONE
AB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR MELENDEZ.
NO JONES SAWYER NO SANTIAGO. ON
SOMETIME TODAY. THE SAME BOOK
ABSTAINED THAT MEASURE FAILS.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN WAS PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR. HE WENT AHEAD OF
ME HAVE TO THE GAVEL PLEASE.
AND GAP. JONES SAWYER REPORT I
AM HOLD ON YOU MEAN OUT OF
ORDER. OF THE GOT VOTED ON. ALL
TIME FOR TO OF ALL TIME. I'LL
BE A VOTE ON LACKEY IT'S
RUNNING ON A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY
LACKEY JONES SAWYER- LET ME
THINK I JONES SAWYER I. GOOD
CHOICE. I BELIEVE THAT WITH IT
AS IT. YEAH ABOUT THAT. TAKE IN
MY OFFICE THIS AFTERNOON.
BEFORE WE STAND ADJOURNED CAKE
IN MY OFFICE. AT. AT THREE
O'CLOCK WE NOW STAND ADJOURNED
WHAT ONE THIRTY